Egyre inkább érzem azt is, hogy
mintogyha egy ilyen buborék vennék
körbe, pont úgy, mint a 99-es.com
buborékot. Nem tudom, hogy nektek mi a
tapasztalatotok ezzel kapcsolatban, hogy
ti hogyan látjátok ezt az AI hullámot. A
klasszikus ipari fejlesztési folyamat az
úgy nézett ki, hogy egy cégben van egy
probléma, valaki előáll egy megoldással,
és akkor azt mondja a cégnek a vezetése,
hogy jól van uraim, kaptok három színes
gombot, költsétek el arra, csináljatok
valami kis demót, amiben megmutatjátok,
hogy működik az ötlet. Ha meggyőztök
minket, hogy működik az ötlet, adunk
több pénzt, hogy csináljátok meg ipari
skálázásra ezt a történetet. De ez abból
a felvetésből indul, hogy amit meg
tudnak csinálni kicsiben, az utána aztán
kicsi pénz ráfolytásával skálázhatóvá
válik ipari méretbe, precízitásban,
technológiában, egyebekben. A mesterség
és intelligencia az egy csapda ilyen
szempontból, mert az pont nem ilyen.
Tehát az történik, hogy egy ilyen nyelvi
modellel, egy egy hasonló technológiával
nagyon-nagyon gyorsan össze lehet rakni
valamit, ami 80%-ban működik. Most
képzeljük el, hogy egy üzleti
intelligencia technoló problémát felvet
egy fő egy vezető, és a technológiai
osztály három napon belül hoz neki egy
olyan megoldást, ami az elmúlt öt éves
üzleti tevékenységből mondjuk az ő jó
üzleti döntéseiknek a 85%-át helyesen
megmondta, és 15-öt nem. Erre a
klasszikus beidegződések alapján minden
menedzser azt mondja, hogy hát srácok,
ha ez két nap alatt 85% lett, tegyünk rá
még egy kicsi pénzt, csináljatok nem
tudom még egy évig, és akkor lesz belőle
mondjuk 99%, és akkor automatikusan
tudunk majd egy csomó jó üzleti döntést
meghozni. Az AI azjában nem ilyen, tehát
ez úgy működik, hogy 85%-ig nagyon
gyorsan eljutunk és utána tovább nagyon
nehéz menni fölfele, és nagyon-nagyon
sok cég, startup, a saját környezetemben
látott ipari projekt abba bukik bele,
hogy a demo nagyon jól sikerül. tesznek
rá egy kicsi pénzt, beépítik a valós
ipari környezetbe, ott is elkezd
működni, ott is egy pici százalék-ot
hoz. És akkor amikor a a döntéshozók
megmondják, hogy jó, viszont ahhoz, hogy
ezt még beengedjük a valós üzleti
folyamatainkba, akkor azt kell, hogy
mondjuk 98%-os pontosságra fel kell
hozni a rendszert, és 95-nél megáll az
élet, és onnantól az földpénzel nem elég
arra, hogy tovább vidd, mert megállt a
rend. Tehát ez a probléma, hogy az a
100%-ig való skálázás, az a 100%-ig való
való pontosság, az legalábbis ezekkel a
technológiákkal ez nem érhető el.
Sziasztok! A mai epizódban Kolumbán
Sándor és Simon Károly volt a vendégem.
Mindketten egyetemi oktatók, de
ugyanakkor a vállalkozói szférában is
igen aktívak. Rengeteg izgalmas témáról
beszélgettünk, többek között arról, hogy
ez az AI hullám valójában nem-e egy
buborék, ami hamarosan kipattan.
Ugyanakkor beszélgettünk erről a
technológiai vadnyugatról, amiben
látszólag Kína és Amerika vezet, és
többek között arról, hogy Európának a
szerepe pontosan hol is van. Ugyanakkor
beszélgettünk arról is, hogy egy fiatal
mit érdemes tanulni a manapság. Annyira
gyorsan változik az információs világ,
annyira sok mindent kell tudni. Vajon
érdemes már egyetemet végezni
egyáltalán? Végezetül pedig beszéltünk a
digitális Székelyföld konferenciáról,
amelyik itt Székelyudvarhelyen lesz
megszervezve október 24-én és 25-én. A
leírásban a videó alatt megtaláljátok a
linket, amin keresztül majd jegyeket
tudtok vásárolni erre a konferenciára.
Nemrég megnéztem részletesen a
csatornámnak a statisztikáit, és
megdöbbenve vettem észre, hogy a
nézőimnek 80%-a még nincs feliratkozva a
csatornára. Ha tetszik ez a tartalom, és
tetszik, amit csinálunk, akkor kérlek,
iratkozz fel, és ezzel segíted a
munkánkat, ezzel segíted, hogy minél
több emberhez eljussanak ezek a
tartalmak.
Ez lesz a 31. epizód, és a mai nap a
digitális székely földről is fogunk
beszélgetni, amelyik viszont a 10.
jubileumi évét fogja megülni, és erről
majd fogunk beszélgetni az műsor második
részében. Viszont rengeteg izgalmas
témával készültem és készültünk, úgyhogy
csapjunk is bele. Üdvözöllek titeket.
>> Sziasztok Bocs.
>> Sziasztok. Üdvözöljük a kedves nézőket
és hallgatókat.
Az egyik legfontosabb kérdés, ami amúgy
foglalkoztat rendszeresen, az az, hogy
egyik oldalról tényleg az van, hogy ez
az AI, ez egy valós valami. Tehát ez ez
nem csak egy hype, amelyik tehát az én
életemben abszolút megjelenik. Kétszer
háromszor produktívabbá váltam az elmúlt
két évben, mint menedzser. Nagyon-nagyon
sokat segít, és a tanulásban segít, a
gyors olvasásban segít, a feladataim
elvégzésében segít. Tehát van valami
valós benne. Viszont egyre inkább érzem
azt is, hogy mintogyha egy ilyen buborék
vennék körbe, pont úgy, mint a 99-es.com
buborékot.
Nem tudom, hogy nektek mi a
tapasztalatotok ezzel kapcsolatban, hogy
ti hogyan látjátok ezt az AI hullámot.
>> Hú, hát nagyon minden igazabból, amit
amit elmondtál. Tehát a mesterséges
intelligenciára
gondolok, akkor én egyelőre szeretek
eszközként gondolni rá. Kétségkívül egy
nagyon hatékony eszköz. Tehát anélkül,
hogy mondjuk úgy elbagatelizálnám a
jelentőségét vagy a az impactját, azért
azért azt tegyük hozzá, hogy legalábbis
egyelőre még nem mindenre jó.
És
ilyen szempontból, hogyha csak a mondjuk
a példát vegyek a saját szakmánkból,
ugye ahol egyre többször elhangzik, hogy
hát ez ki fogja váltani mondjuk egyre
inkább a programozókat, ezzel a
megközelítéssel
nagyon nem értek egyet, mert ha
belegondolunk, akkor
eddig is voltak nagyon jó eszközeink,
meg évről évre jobb eszközeink. Ugye
sokszor beszéltünk erről a
technológiai fejlődésnek az
exponenciális üteméről és arról, hogy
benne élve hajlamosak vagyunk ezt
másképp megélni. Tehát hajlamosak
vagyunk mondjuk ezt úgy lineárisként
megélni. És akkor akkor elfelejtjük,
hogy hát ne menjünk vissza a
lyukártyákig, de elfelejtjük, hogy
mondjuk milyen volt, amikor
mondjuk szöveges üzemmódban írtunk
programkódot, amit utána egy értelmező
szépen szekvenciálisan végrehajtott,
vagy utána milyen volt, amikor még
mondjuk a
statikus ellenőrzéseket végző linterek
nem voltak egybe építve, ugye a fordít
vagy összeintegrálva fordítókkal, ugye
külön kellett ezeket használni. Én még
használtam ekkora flopit. Így igen. Ezt
a félig A4-es, A5-ös flopit meg.
>> Igen. Így van. És aztán innen hogy
jutottunk, vagy hogy mentünk végig azon
a azon az időszakon, amikor már egyre
jobbak és jobbak voltak a fejlesztői
környezeteink, egyre többet segítettek a
munkánkba.
Aztán igazából már évtizedekkel ezelőtt
végül is voltak olyan eszközök, amiknek
ha én megmondtam, hogy milyen adataim
vannak, akkor gyakorlatilag egy teljes
projektvázat le tudtak
ö
generálni.
generálni nekünk. Hajlamosak vagyunk
elfelejteni azt is, hogy hogy milyen
volt mondjuk úgy programozni a Google
előtti időkben, vagy vagy utána a Steck
Overflow nélkül. Tehát, hogy én azt
gondolom, hogy ebbe a trendbe épülnek
bele most gyakorlatilag azok az eszközök
is, amiket például, ahogy te is mondtad,
a mindennapi munkánk során használunk,
AI eszközök, amik amik igen sokkal
hatékonyabbá tudják
tenni a munkánkat, de csak akkor, hogyha
hogyha értünk hozzá
akkor tudjuk ezeket igazán hatékonyan
hatékonyan használni. Szóval én továbbra
is egyrészt egy eszközként próbálok meg
erre tekinteni. Hogyha egy picit jövőben
tekintünk, akkor azért elég nehéz
jósolni, hogy ez ez merre fog alakulni.
Ugye itt van nekünk olyan volt
kollégánk, akivel már hét-nyolc évvel
ezelőtt is lehetett fogadni, hogy
2029-re meglesz a szingularitás együtt
az erős vagy általános célú mesterséges
intelligenciával, sőt utána már 2027-re
is fogadott.
Én fogadtam vele, de nem vagyok biztos
benne, hogy hogy nem ő fog nyerni.
Lássuk.
>> Igen. Hát a 27 az tényleg közel van, és
ki tudja. Igen.
>> Nagyjából egyetértek azzal, amit Kor ezt
mondott. Ide két dolgot tennék hozzá. Az
egyik egy kicsit ilyen technológiai
részébe belemenve a ennek a mesterséges
intelligenciás történetnek ma minden,
ami körül ez a hype van, nevezzük akkor
hyp-nak. Ez alapvetően ezek a nagy
nyelvi modellek és a ráépülő
technológiák, agentek és egyebek. Tehát
azt kell látni, hogy hogy ez a
technológia ennek van egy pár
beleépített korlátozása. Az egyik ilyen
korlátozás például az, hogy ez csak a
múltból dolgozik. Tehát ő nem tud új
dolgokat kitalálni. Abban nagyon erős,
hogy ami amit már valaha látott, és
lehet, hogy nem együtt látta, hanem csak
összerakja valahonnan, de a múltból
szedi elő a dolgokat. Ennek olyan
következményei vannak, hogy például új
dolgokat nem fog tudni előállítani, vagy
nagyon újakat. Mondok egy példát, hogy a
szoftverfejlesztésben ez hol lyukat ki.
Ha csak megnézzük mondjuk a
webfejlesztésnek a technológiai
fejlődését, évente új keretrendszerek
jelentek meg, amik filozófiailag új
alapokon nyugodtak. Na most ilyet nem
várhatunk tőle. Tehát mindegyik nyilván
JavaScript alapú keretrendszert, tehát a
JavaScript nyelv létezik, tudjuk
JavaScript programozni az összes EI, de
azt senki nem gondolja, hogy egyik
pillanatra a másikra ő kitalálta volna
mondjuk a React keretrendszert, és akkor
abba kezdett volna el dolgozni. Nyilván
ez mondjuk emberekre van szabva, tehát
úgy lett jobb, hogy az emberek számára
jobb. Tehát nem biztos, hogy ez mondjuk
egy AI-nak egyáltalán szempont, de ettől
függetlenül ilyen új dolgokat ő nem
nagyon csinál. A másik dolog, ami ami
viszonylag szerintem most már nagyon
szépen látszik, és igazából a Silikon
Worldben is többen beismerik,
bemutatják, ha valaki nézte a a leg
legfrissebb open-t, akkor ezt láthatja,
hogy valójában ez a technológia, ez ez
azért elég szépen platózott. A egy
nagyon rövid történeti áttekintés,
amikor
valakinek a szilikonvölgyben eszébe
jutott, hogy próbálják ki azt a dolgot,
hogy hogy szupert túlskálázzák ezeket a
modelleket, tehát óriásra megcsinálják.
Lássuk, hogy mi sül ki ebből. A
tudományos konszenzus az az volt előtte,
hogy ennek nincs értelme, mert ha nagyon
túskálázzuk a dolgokat, akkor pontosan
rátanul a tanuló adatokra, és nem lesz
kép úgynevezett általánosításra. Tehát
hogyha olyan kérdést teszel fel nekem,
ami nem volt benne a tanuló
adathalmazában, akkor hogyha túlítottunk
egy modellt, akkor nagyon fura dolgokat
fog mondani. Na most az történt, hogy
kipróbálták ezt a túlskálázást, és az
derült ki, hogy igazából nagyon jó
válaszokat ad a túlskálázott modell, és
valami olyasmi lett a filozófiai
háttérben, hogy itt nincsenek zajok az
adatban, tehát nem az történik, mint
amikor mondjuk meg szeretnénk becsülni,
hogy egy voltmérő az mennyire precízen
méri a feszültséget, és akkor mérünk
ugyanazon a feszültségen egyszer 5,1-et,
egyszer 4,9 volt, és van egy picike zaj.
De valójában mi ötöt akarunk látni, és
akkor azt a zajt ki kell szűrni a
tanulással, hanem itt az történik, hogy
mondjuk megtanították neki a Petőfi
összest, meg a Shakespeare összest és
egyebeket, de ott amikor mondjuk azt
nézzük meg, hogy két magyar szó után
melyik harmadik következik, a Petőfiben
nincsenek zajuk, tehát nem az van, hogy
ő nyertanilag rosszul írt rá valamit, és
ezért ki kéne szűrni valamit, hanem
minden, ami ott van, az valójában
tanulandó. És valami ilyesmiből
következik az, hogy a ez a túltanulás,
ez valójában nem rontott a dolgokon, de
ettől függetlenül az az adatkupac, ami
ott neki rendelkezésre áll, az véges. És
az egy hatalmas mérnöki teljesítmény
volt, hogy gyakorlatilag a teljes írott
emberi tudásállományt azt be tudták
tolni, mint tanulóadat, de annak
elértünk a végére. Tehát, hogy ma már
ennél sokkal többet nem látunk. És ez
látszik is, ha valaki visszanézi az
elmúlt néhány év trendjét, akkor
megjelenik a chat GPT, megjelenik a
négyes-tös modellek satöbbik, és tényleg
ugranak fölfele a dolgok. És ha mondjuk
valaki megnézi az idei open devday-t,
akkor azt látja, hogy semmilyen új
modell nem jelenik meg, semmilyen nagy
extrát nem szólnak. Igazából most már az
van, hogy API-n keresztül használhatóak
a modellek a fejlesztésbe, könnyebben
beintegrálhatóvá tették a modelleket,
agenteket lehet csinálni, elmegyünk abba
az irányba, hogy ami egy pár éve is már
amúgy is trend volt, hogy ilyen kódolás
nélkül fejlesztünk szoftvert. Ilyen no
code technológiák, ebbe próbálják
belehúzni a az open szolgáltatásait, de
valójában a következő nagy lépés nem
történt meg. És pont amiatt, hogy ez egy
ilyen prediktív technológia, legalábbis
nagy nyelvű modellek, ettől én és még
nagyon sokan igazából nem várják, hogy
ettől jön a majd a nagy megváltás a
mesterség és intelligencia terén. Ez nem
jelenti azt, hogy valami más technológia
nem fogja elhozni, de ez a mostani ez
nem fogja elhozni. És még egy
megjegyzés, hogy itt a buborék kapcsán
mi történik.
A klasszikus ipari fejlesztési folyamat
az úgy nézett ki, hogy egy cégben van
egy probléma, valaki előáll egy
megoldással, és akkor azt mondja a
cégnek a vezetése, hogy jól van uraim,
kaptok három színes gombot, költsétek el
arra, csináljatok valami kis demót,
amiben megmutatjátok, hogy működik az
ötlet. Ha meggyőztök minket, hogy
működik az ötlet, adunk több pénzt, hogy
csináljátok meg ipariálázásra ezt a
történetet. De ez abból a felvetésből
indul, hogy amit meg tudnak csinálni
kicsiben, az utána aztán kicsi pénz
ráfordításával skálázhatóvá válik ipari
méretbe, precizitásban, technológiában,
egyebekben. A mesterség és intelligencia
az egy csapda ilyen szempontból, mert az
pont nem ilyen. Tehát az történik, hogy
egy ilyen nyelvi modellel, egy egy
hasonló technológiával nagyon-nagyon
gyorsan össze lehet rakni valamit, ami
80%-ban működik. Most képzeljük el, hogy
egy üzleti intelligencia technoló
problémát felvet egy fő fő egy vezető,
és a technológiai osztály három napon
belül hoz neki egy olyan megoldást, ami
az elmúlt öt éves üzleti
tevékenységből mondjuk a a az ő jó
üzleti döntéseiknek a 85%-át helyesen
megmondta, és 15-öt nem. Erre a
klasszikus beidegződések alapján minden
menedzser azt mondja, hogy hát srácok,
ha ez két nap alatt 85% lett, tegyünk rá
még egy kicsi pénzt, csináljatok nem
tudom még egy évig, és akkor lesz belőle
mondjuk 99%, és akkor automatikusan
tudunk majd egy csomó jó üzleti döntést
meghozni. Az AI azában nem ilyen. Tehát
ez úgy működik, hogy 85%-ig nagyon
gyorsan eljutunk és utána tovább nagyon
nehéz menni fölfele és nagyon-nagyon sok
cég, startup, a saját környezetemben
látott ipari projekt abba bukik bele,
hogy a demó nagyon jól sikerül. Tesznek
rá egy kicsi pénzt, beépítik a valóspari
környezetbe, ott is elkezd működni, ott
is egy pici százalék-ot hoz. És akkor
amikor a a döntéshozók megmondják, hogy
jó, viszont ahhoz, hogy ezt m beengedjük
a valós üzleti folyamatainkba, akkor azt
kell mondjuk 98%-os pontosságra fel kell
hozni a rendszert, és 95-nél megáll az
élet, és onnantól az föld pénzzel nem
elég arra, hogy tovább vidd, mert
megállt a rend. Tehát ez a probléma,
hogy az a 100%-ig való skálázás, az a
100%-ig való való pontosság, az
legalábbis ezekkel a technológiákkal ez
nem érhető el. Amúgy rengeteg dolgot
feldobtál, kicsit birkóznék ezekkel a
gondolatokkal, főleg azért, mert én is
meg akarom érteni jobban. Nekem
sincsenek kész válaszaim. De pont hogy
említetted ezt a 85% és 15%-ot, mert az
egyik nagy buborék, ami nemrég pattant
ki most olvastam
a erről a erről a botrányról, a
builder.ai AI volt, aki már évekkel
ezelőtt, pontosabban két éve már azt
hirdette, hogy AI által generált
applikációkat
szolgáltatnak. 80%-ban megírja az AI, és
a 20% az a human factor, tehát az amikor
valaki konkrétan a kliensel leül,
adaptálja a részleteket, elsimítja
és a Microsoft is befektetett ebbe
többek között, és az egyik leggyorsabban
növekvő startup volt, ilyen igazi
unicorn is. És most nemrég derül ki pár
hónapja, hogy valójában indiai
fejlesztők fejlesztettek a háttérben.
Tehát gyakorlatilag olcsó kétkezi
munkásokat dolgoztattak a háttérbe, és
becsomagolták úgy, mint AI által
generált applikáció, úgyhogy nagyot
robbant. én meg is néztem a honlap már
nem elérhető, tehát hogy a a domain is
le lett zárva, úgyhogy ez és és
valójában tényleg azt érzem, hogy mint a
mint 1999-ben, ami a.com körül volt, egy
kicsit esetleg a nézők kedvéért
frissítsük fel, hogy mi is történt ott.
Az internet elterjedésével egy ilyen
hurrá optimizmus lett
urrá mindenkin.
És gyakorlatilag minden egyes startup,
amelyik azt mondta, hogy az interneten
egy valamilyen.com végződésű domént
megvásárol és valamit fog szolgáltatni,
kapott egy befektetést. És ezeknek a
befektetéseknek egy jó része, azért,
hogy ne maradjanak le az emberek
befektettek, viszont egy jó részéről
kiderült, hogy nem annyira hasznos,
tehát igazi értéket nem termel. És
99-ben robbant ki ez a lufi. Valami
hasonlót érzek én is, hogy van valami
valós, ami köré épül egy nagy buborék.
És jó lenne megérteni, hogy mi is az,
ami valós ebbe, és mi az, ami buborék.
És és amit te is megfogalmaztál, hogy az
igazi érték ott kell legyen. Egyszerűen
nem elegendő, hogyha valami csilivil jó
ötlet és be van csomagolva és és nagyon
gyorsan el lehet jutni 80%-ig, mert
utána aztán viszont nagyon nehéz.
Szóval itt itt az egyik kérdés, ami
felmerül bennem, az az, hogy vajon nem-e
az kell legyen, akkor a világ
hozzászokik a 80%-os megoldásokhoz, vagy
pedig erre való valójában tényleg nem
lehet bizniszeket építeni. Tehát, hogy
most mondok egy példát. Egy szervezet
azt mondja, hogy én szeretnék számlákat
feldolgozni, és elegendő, hogyha 80%-ban
működik, vagy 90%-ban, mert 10 emberből
elegendő csak két ember utána, hogy
átnéze ezeket a számlákat. És eddig 10
ember nézte manuálisan, most pedig AI
által csak két ember fogja nézni. Erre
mit mondanál?
>> Ó, hát itt itt két dolog. Az egyik,
amiről nagyon jól rátapintottál és ki is
hagytam az előbb, az az, hogy
rászokunk-e arra, hogy elég a 85%.
Szerintem ez nem rászokás kérdése, hanem
van, ahol elég és van, ahol nem elég.
Tehát vannak olyan felhasználói esetek,
mondok egy példát, kis cégem van,
gyorsan akarok csinálni egy egy
reklámspotot, kell egy illusztráció, és
akkor azt mond, hogy mest légyszíves
csinál nekem egy olyan fényképet, amin
egy tengerparton
féllávú mankós pingvinek ugrálnak és a
koktélomat iszák. Nagyon frankó képet
fog csinálni. Lehet, hogy nem fog
tetszeni, mert mit tudom én, a háttérbe
berak egy autót, meg látszik egy
autópályának a korlátja, de úgy vagyok
vele, hogy nem érdekel, mert kiteszem,
két napig kell ott legyen, le fog jönni,
menjünk tovább, pörögjen az élet. Itt
bőven elég jó a 85%. Nem fogok belekötni
abba, hogy zöld helyett, kék
hátterettet, vagy a pingvinnek mit tudom
én, egy kicsit hosszabb kéne legyen a
csőre, mert valójában nem fontos.
Ugyanez van szöveggenálásnál is. Tehát
én amire rendszeresen használom az AI-t,
a gondolataimat felírom ilyen kis
bajuszkákkal, gondolatjelekkel, hogy mit
szeretnék, és megmondom, hogy lic rakd
össze, mert kell egy koherens féloldalas
szöveget írjak. átfutom és lehet, hogy
nem az nem tökéletes a szóhasználat meg
pár dolgot kihagyben, ami olyan
kijavítgatom, de úgyok vele, hogy ez egy
email lesz valakinek, el fogja olvasni,
tudja, hogy mit akarok mondani, érteni
fogja belőle, nem kell precíz legyen. Na
most ha atom atomerőmű irányításról meg
robotpilótákról, meg ipari folyamatok
irányításáról, meg céges ERP
rendszerekről beszélgetünk, itt nem fér
bele a 85%.
Ami pedig nagyon-nagyon fontos ezeknél a
digitalizációs projekteknél, az az, hogy
automatizálni olyasmit érdemes, amit
utána tudott vállalni azt a
következményt, ami az automatizációval
jár, mégpedig azt, hogy utána ezt
emberek mivel nem csinálják, elveszlődik
a tudásod. Tehát az történik, hogy mi
beteszünk egy automatizmust a
rendszerbe, ez kivált erőforrást, azt az
erőforrást nyilván felszabadítjuk,
eltesszük máshova, utána ha ez az
automatizmus megkattan, félreugrik,
satöbbi, hirtelen nekünk nem lesz amivel
helyettesíteni. Tehát én mondjuk nagyon
aggódnék egy olyan üzleti folyamatban,
ahol egy CG GPT is API van használva
arra, hogy valamit működjön, és egyszer
csak nem tudom, a modellt lecserélik,
átalakítják, kiveszik supportból az
egyik modellt, esznek egy másikat
helyette, és nekem egyik napl a másikba
elromlik az üzleti folyamatom, és már
nincsen emberem, aki azt kézzel
csinálni, mert már régtam őket máshova.
Tehát lesznek helyek, ahol van értelme.
Szerintem az ilyen szabadabb, nem
annyira fontos, vagy vagy nem olyan
hosszútávú dolgokban ez meg fogja
találni a helyét, és lesznek helyek,
ahol ahol ennek nincs helye. A szoftver
fejlesztés amúgy szerintem ilyen. Tehát
én nem gondolom, hogy egy olyan banki
szoftvert, ahol a félvilág összes
tranzakciója keresztül megy és
elszámoltató kell legyen, és jogilag
rendben kell legyen, azt fogják engedni
valaha, hogy emberi felügyelet nélkül AI
fejleszten nyilván lehet benne segíteni,
de ez nem nem fog soha odáig eljutni,
hogy hogy csak ők csinálják ezeket a
dolgokat. És akkor neked mi a
megérzésed, hogy valójában több
fejlesztőre vagy kevesebb fejlesztőre
lesz szükség a jövőben, mert igazából
mind a kettő mellett lehet érvelni.
>> Én én nem akarom Karestől a szót
teljesen elcsalni. Nekem az az érzésem,
hogy a a technológiai fejlődésben az
igény még nem érkezett meg. Tehát az
történt, hogy nagyon gyorsan lett egy
technológiai fejlődésünk. A
szolgáltatása a szoftver fejlesztési
szektornak az nagyon megugrott. Tehát
hatékonyabbak lettünk, gyorsabak
lettünk, ez igaz. De ezt a keresleti
oldal még nem látta. Tehát azok azok a
projektek, amiket 5-10 éve adtunk egy
árajánlatot, és a projekt belátta, hogy
gazdaságilag neki nem éri meg ezen a
költségen ezt lefejlesztetni,
leeresztette az órát, és szomorúan
elkogott, hogy márpedig az ő szíve várja
nem fog megvalósulni. Ma ott tartunk,
hogyha ugyanez a projekt visszajönne,
akkor mondjuk egy fele ilyen árat, vagy
nem felé, de mondjuk mint két-hármada
árat tudnék mondani rá. Ezt az emberek
mi a technológiai szektorban látjuk,
hogy ilyen ennyit ugrott lefele az
árunk, viszont a kereslet ezt még nem
látja. Szerintem egy-két év alatt amúgy
is a gazdasági válság, tehát a gazdasági
helyzet eleve nem olyan, mint mondjuk
négy-öt éve, de ha a gazdaság is helyre
állna, és a az emberekbe tudatosulna,
hogy amiket ők szeretnének, azokat most
már mennyivel olcsóbban megkaphatják,
szerintem a szoftverfejlesztés utáni
igény az vissza fog mászni. Tehát én én
egyáltalán nem gondolom azt, hogy ha
eddig 200 embert engedett ki egyetem a
kapuján informatikus diplomával, akkor
jövőre le kéne húzni a helyeket csak
100-ra, mert nem lesz rájuk szükség. Ez
szerintem ez egy ez egy rövid kis átmet
időszak, amikor nincs annyi igény a
fejlesztőkre, de ez vissza fog mászni,
meg fog jelenni az igény is rá, és akkor
onnantól kezdve visszatérünk oda, ahol
szépen majd kiegyensúlyozza egymást ez a
keresletkínálat. Apropó igénykaresz meg,
te mit látsz most így rendszerűen, hogy
az egyetemeken hány jelentkező van, mert
négy évvel ezelőtt még az egyetemi
padból is kiszedték a a cégek a a
diákokat, akik egy picit értettek
bármihez is. Most viszont nem ezt látom.
Tehát hogy erről a trendről te mit
tudnál mondani? Mi a mi a tapasztalatod?
van egy jelentős visszaesés
lokálisan is, de globálisan is. Tehát az
informatika vagy az informatikához
kapcsolódó szakok népszerűsége az az
jelentősen visszaesett.
Ennek ugye a hátterében
nagy részt az áll, hogy maga magának
maga magá a szektoron belül volt egy egy
visszaesés. És viszont egy kicsit az
előző témához hozzákötve ezt, én nem
gondolom azt, hogy ennek kimondottan a
mesterséges intelligencia lenne az oka.
Tehát ennek az okai ennél
összetettebbek. Egyrészt ugye van egy
globális, mondjuk úgy piaci
átrendeződés, ami ezt ezt befolyásolja.
Van egy globális, finoman fogalmazva,
nem könnyű
gazdasági helyzet, ami arra késztett
nagyon sok nagy szereplőt, hogy hogy
óvatosabb legyen, hogy kivárjon, hogy
hogy visszavágjon fejlesztési
büdzsékből, és hát ezt ezt érzi a
szektor. Ezenkívül a az IT esetében volt
egy buborék is, tehát hogy volt egy ugye
a
covidőszakban egy hirtelen, legalábbis
bizonyos területeken nagyon hirtelen és
nagyon erőteljesen megnövekedett igény.
És ezt nagyon sokan azt gondolták, hogy
ez ez ilyen trendszerű lesz, tehát hogy
ez meg fog maradni, de nem így történt.
Tehát vissza visszaestek ezek a rész,
nem tudom, doméniumok, és ugye ez azt
azt eredményezte, hogy a bőség
időszakában nagyon sok embert akár
túl mondhatjuk azt, hogy túl nagy
kompromisszumokkal felvettek ezek a
cégek, mert majd lesz projekt. Aztán nem
lett projekt, és és ezektől az
emberektől meg kellett meg kellett
váljanak. Tehát, hogy hogy volt egy
ilyen egy egy ilyen lufi is, ami ami
kipukkad. És hát, hogyha már az IT
szektor ne
nehéz helyzetéről, vagy jelenlegi nem
könnyű helyzetéről beszélünk, vagy
mondjuk úgy, hogy egy kihívásokkal teli
állapotról beszélünk per pillanat, az
lokálisan arra még rátett egy egy
lapáttal, tehát hogy országos
szinten nézzük, akkor
egyrészt az országos gazdasági helyzet
is, másrészt ugye a az adórendszernek
gyakorlatilag a az átalakulása. Tehát
sok tényező együttes hatása ez a
visszaesés.
És persze ezzel együtt jön a mesterséges
intelligencia, ami nagyobb hatékonyságot
eredményez. Azért ezt
ezt nincs amiért, vagy ahogy ahogy
vitatni. Tehát gyakorlatilag
ö kevesebb ember egységi idő alatt több
munkát tud elvégezni, több értéket tud
termelni, és mindez együttesen
okozza ezt az állapotot, amiről az imént
beszéltünk. hogy ez már tart egy ideje,
tehát ez azért nem a múlt héten
kezdődött, hanem ennek már ez már tart
egy ideje, és nyilván ezt a ezt a
fiatalok is látják, úgyhogy
ilyen ennek nagyrészt valószínű ennek
tudható be ez a jelenlegi visszaesés.
hogy mi lesz hosszabb távon. Ezt hát
erre nehéz nehéz jósolni, de én itt itt
Sándorról értenék egyet, hogy hogyha
hosszabb távon nézzük, akkor ez
valószínű egyfajta stabilizálódás lesz.
Tehát valószínű, hogy nem fogja
nem fog visszaérni ez a az igény
ugyanarra a szintre, ami ami volt ugye
az előbb említett buborék időszakában.
de újra
növekedésnek növekedésnek fog indulni.
Nyilván ennek az átmeneti időszaknak
azért
azért meglesz az ára is és és meglesznek
az áldozata is.
>> Igen. Hát az biztos, hogy most egy egy
válságkelős közepén vagyunk. És
az egyik dolog, amit nemrég értettem
meg, és számomra nagyon izgalmas
gondolat volt, az az, hogy valójában
mindig a kicsi cégek azok, akik
innovatívak.
A nagy cégek azok nem tudnak innovatívak
lennie, és ennek az oka számon színeknek
volt a gondolata.
Ő mondta, hogy hogy a nagy cégeknél
azon, hogy annyi erőforrásuk van, hogy
hogy valójában a vágyaikat be tudják
teljesíteni velük. Tehát az, ami céljuk
van, azt el tudják érni azokból az
erőforrásokból, a hatalmas cégek. A
kicsi cé cégek viszont egyfolytában a a
fennmaradásért küzdenek. És amikor
amikor valakinek kevesebb az erőforrása,
mint amennyi álma van, akkor innovatív
kell legyen, akkor valamit ki kell
találjon. És ezt abszolút érzem a mi
kicsi cégünkön is, hogy most kezdünk el
innoválni. És amúgy látom Sándor is,
hogy hogy folyamatosan azon nagy az,
hogy hogyan lehetne valamit kitalálni.
Tehát, hogy a a az akadémiai
pályafutásod mellett van egy nagyon erős
ilyen befektetői vénád is, és egy ilyen
innovatív startupos vénád is. És
és igen, tehát hogy azt érzem, hogy ez a
ez a válság egyszer azt is hozza elő
belőlünk, tehát hogy jó jó néhány
cégből, hogy hogy ki kell találjuk a
jövőt, kell innováljunk. Viszont a másik
probléma, amivel egyfolytában küzdök,
valószínűleg ez egy ilyen
posztkommunista kisebbségérzésből
származik, hogy itt van a Nagy Amerika,
mint az egyik hatalmas innovatív ilyen
ilyen powerhouse, és ott van most Kína
is. Gyakorlatilag ők ketten az, akik
dominálják a piacot. És én Európát nem
látom sehol a kettő között, vagy nagyon
kevés olyan cég van, akik akik most a
misál jut eszembe, akik például AI
szempontjából még valahol ott vannak a a
térképen. Még lehet egy pár, de ahhoz
képest, hogy a top 50-ben hány kínai és
amerikai van, úgy úgy elbizonytalanodok.
Először is az első kérdésem az, hogy ti
hol látjátok Európa helyzetét a két nagy
óriás között?
Jó, hát itt itt több dolgot is
felvetettél, akkor próbálok ezekre
reagálni. Egyébként itt az Európa
helyzetét én picit picit árnyaltabbnak
látom. Először reagálnék arra, hogy ez a
cégek, innováció
nyilvánvalóan, hogy erre a relatíve új
helyzetre a a cégek valahogyan kell
válaszoljanak. Én itt ilyen sz olyan
szempontból optimista vagyok. Én azt
látom, hogy hogy hogy ezt ezt nagyon sok
cég megértette, és nagyon sok cég keresi
a megoldásokat, és
és hogy mondjam
okot adhat optimizmusra az
amerre amerre tartanak. Például ugye
főleg nálunk nagyon jellemző volt, hogy
és jelen pillanatban is jellemző, hogy a
legtöbb helyi cég outsourcing
tevékenységet folytat. még akkor is,
hogyha ez már rég egyszerű ilyen
bérfejlesztést jelent, hogy hogy úgymond
kiadjuk az embereinket, de a
projektmenedzsment meg a
meg egyéb
nagyobb értéket hozzáadó tevékenységek a
fejlesztés máshol történnek. Ez ez már
rég nem így van. Tehát jellemzően azért
itt a konkrétan a ezek az outsource
cégek azért a szoftverfejlesztésnek a
mondjuk ugy a teljes életciklusát
lefedik
beleírtve tervezést a fejlesztési
folyamat menedzsmentjét a konkrét
fejlesztést tehát hogy ez ez már nem
esetleg nem ők használják majd a
terméket vagy nem ők értékesítik de de
ilyen szempontból egy komoly
értékteremtő munkát folytatnak viszont
ez továbbra is azért jellemzően egy
outsourceing tevékenység ami visszaesett
tehát eb ebben az új helyzetben
jelentősebben visszaesett. Viszont ezt
ezt nagyon sok cég kezdi felismerni, és
nagyon sok cég elindult, helyi cégek is
a ugye ahogy mondtad a termékfejlesztés
az innováció irányába, illetve a piacok
szempontjából is, hogyha most az európai
ipar, illetve gazdaság bizonyos
szegmensei meg vagy szektorei
megakadtak,
akkor azt látjuk, akik egyébként
ügyfelei voltak ezeknek a helyi
cégeknek, akkor azt látjuk, hogy ezek a
ezek közül a cégek közül
sokan próbálnak nyitani más piacok
piacok fele is. Tehát világos, hogy a
cégeknek kell reagáljanak egy ilyen
ilyen helyzetre, de azt látjuk, hogy ez
nem tudom, hogy a megfelelő ütembe-e, de
megtörténik. Ugyanúgy az előző
kérdésedre egy picit visszatérve,
ugyanígy az oktatási intézményeknek is
kell reagálniuk erre a erre az új
állapotra, hogy vissza kell visszaesett
legalábbis ideglenesen a az igény.
Valószínű, hogy hogy hogy adaptálni kell
a hát az egész rendszert, a a
folyamatokat. Ez ugyanúgy, ahogy a
cégeknek vagy az oktatási intézményeknek
is
is meg kell lépniük. Most a másik
részére a kérdésednek ez a az Európa
helyzeteit Amerika, Kínav játékosok
közötte. Én látok azért, tehát hogy én
azért mondtam, hogy árnyalatnak látom,
mert én látok innovációt
Európában. Most világos, hogy azért a
kínai számokkal azért
nehéz
versenyezni, meg az is világos, hogy és
nem is új dolog, hogy azért a az IT
fejlesztéseknek és innovációknak azért
az előzőekben is egy jelentős központja
az Egyesült Államok volt ugye a
elsősorban ugye a silicium völdnek a
környéke. De például, hogyha európai
példát mondok, egy nagyon-nagyon komoly
innovációs központnak tartom én például
Berlint, tehát nagyon-nagyon sok
izgalmas
startup van, beleértve akár
akár unikornisokat is, az milliárd euró
fölötti érték értékelésű jel
startupokat. Tehát, hogy nem nem
gondolom azt, hogy hogy ilyen
szempontból nem lehet úgymond labdába,
vagy nem tudunk labdába rúgni, vagy akár
szűkebb régiónkból is azért azt látjuk,
hogy
hogy nagyon sok szakember el tud érni
tényleg a világszintű világszintű
élvonalba, és és hozzá tud adni
értéket
ehhez ehhez az egész történetethe.
Úgyhogy ez olyan egy olyan
szövegkörnyezetben, ahol ez egyébként
nem könnyű, mert rengetegen rengetegen
vannak, akik ezzel foglalkoznak. Úgyhogy
úgyhogy nem olyan könnyű ebből
kiemelkedőt alkotni, és mégis vannak
mégis vannak erre szép számmal példák,
úgyhogy
úgyhogy én ilyen szempontból azt
gondolom, hogy hogy pályán vagyunk még
ebben a játékban. És egyébként itt még
egy egy megjegyzés, hogy még talán a
közelkeletet kihagytad ebből a
felsorolásból, mert ott is nagyon erős
ilyen innovációs
>> Igen. Emlékszem, hogy volt Sándor neked
egy előadásod az innovációról pár éve,
>> és nagyon megragadt a fejemben, hogy
hogy valójában nem, most nyilván nem
tudunk versenyezni a kínai és az
amerikai számokkal önmagában, de viszont
egy mutatót mutattál be, amelyik
valójában az egységnyi, tehát a
lakosságra eső innovációt mutatta be,
hogy gyakorlatilag per 1 millió lakos
hány innovatív
valamilyen mérőszámot hoztál erő egy
kicsit megkérlek, hogy mesélj, de ami
külön megragadt engem, az a a az az,
hogy
Izrael mennyire innovatív, tehát hogy a
közelkeletre most Izraelre értett
gyanítom.
És nem csak lehet, de egy kicsit mesélj
erről, hogy most így a térképen hol
vannak az innovációs forrópontok.
>> Ez az, amikor akasztják a hóhért.
őszintén megmondom, nem tudom, hogy
milyen számra gondoltál. val emlékszem,
hogy valamilyen EUs statisztikákat
néztem, hogy ilyen befektetések per
kapita meg hasonlók, hogy jönnek ki, de
pont azt írtam fel a jegyzetemben, hogy
az ilyesmit azt mindig a kiművelt fők
arányában kell tekinteni. Tehát hogyha
azt nézzük meg, hogy mondjuk
Magyarország egy legyünk optimisták 9
milliós ország, Románia egy 15-16
milliós ország, akkor nem ezt kell
Kínával meg Amerikával összenézni, mert
Kínában egy falu akkora, mint nálunk az
egész megye. Tehát, hogy ez nem ez egy
ez nem egy korrekt verseny. A másik
dolog, amit szerintem nagyon fontos itt
látni, hogy ugyan tömbösödés a világban,
meg egyebek, de azt látni kell, hogy
ebben a a nyugati euroatlanti világban
azért nagyon nagy volt, és jelenleg is
még nagyon nagy a mozgás. Tehát ugyanz,
hogy van egy Amerikában bejegyzett
startup, ami az amerikai tőzsdén fut,
annak azért a humán erőforrásának egy
jelentős része simán lehet, hogy az
európai oktatási rendszerből jött ki
európai állampolgárok és a többi, és a
többi. Tehát ez most persze egy kicsit
így töredezik meg recseg, ropog, de ott
nagyon nagy a flexibilitás. Tehát az,
hogy mondjuk egy ausztrál cég vagy egy
egy ukrán cég úgy gondolta ezelőtt, hogy
a jogrendszer Amerikában kedvezőbb
annak, hogy befekteté szerezzen, simán
átmentek és bejegyezték ott a céget.
Tehát azok a gazdasági számok, hogy hol
mennyi az innovatív cég, meg melyik a
tőzsdén, hogy ketyeg, ez igazából egy
régiónak a az innovatív emberek
kiprodukálására
alkalmasságát jelző számait nem tudja
jól alátámasztani. Tehát ez az egyik
dolog, amit mondtam volna. A másik
pedig, ami nagyon fontos,
>> tehát hogy lehet, hogy inkább politikai
meg adózási okok azok, amik egy ez
egyik,
>> amik mutatják egy országban meglevő
cégeknek a számá.
>> Így van. És és az, hogy azok a cégek
honnan hozták az embert, az igazából
sehol nincs kutatva. Tehát mi nem látjuk
azt, hogy egy amerikai tőzsdén jegyzett,
nem tudom az unikornisok hány
százalékában van, mondjuk nem tudom,
Oxfordban, Cambridge-ben, Párizsban,
Budapesten képzett szakember. És úgy
van, hogy ezek az emberek és azt látok
még annyira mobilisak, hogyha egyszer
csak valami úgy alakulna, kis túlzással
pici papírmunka és három héten belül
simán lesz belőlük magyar luxemburgi
vagy holland cég. Tehát, hogy ez nem ez
ilyen szempontból nem ennyire kötött.
Nyilván mondjuk kínai cég nem nagyon
lesz egy amerikai ból, meg Amerika sem
egy kínai ból, mert ott azért kicsit
nagyobb a szakadék, de hogy ez az
euroatlanti világ ez ilyen. És Európának
ami egy nagyon nagy hátránya
ugyan annyira nem értek hozzá, de ez ha
valaki egy kicsit foglalkozik vele,
azonnal látja, hogy az állítás igaz,
hogy tőkepiacilag tehát ezek a a cégek
akkora befektetéseket igényelnek, hogy
ezt kis közösségek nem tudják előadni.
Tehát amikor az openi elmondja, hogy
hány millió dollárt égetnek el hetente,
havonta arra, hogy ők valamit
csináljanak, az nem reális elvárás, hogy
egy Magyarország vagy egy Románia
tőzsdéje előteremtsen egy ilyen pénzt.
Európában például nincsen közös tőzsde,
tehát van magyar tőzsde, rokán tőzsde,
svéd tőzsde, francia tőzsde. Amerikában
a tőzsd ott is van több, de sokkal
inkább az van a fejében az embereknek,
hogy mi amerikaiakikak vagyunk, ez egy
amerikai tőzsde és Romániából és
Magyarországon is vesznek az amerikai
tőzsdén befektetéseket, értékpapírokat
satöbbi. Tehát az történik, hogy hogy
ott egyszerűen nagy a tőkekoncentráció
és ebben az ilyen unikornisokkal
teletűzdelt innovatív világban itt nem
pár százer eurókból kell labdába rúgni,
hanem mondjuk egy ilyen nyelvi modellnek
csak a tanítása, euró milliókról
beszélgetünk, amikor talán emlékeznek a
hallgatók, volt a egy ilyen nagy ugrás,
amikor a kínaiak előkerültek a a
médiában, és amikor a a deepnek a
modellje megjelent és mindenki mondta,
hogy úristen, 7 millió dollárból a Deep
megcsinálta, amit az Open EI nem tudom
mennyi pénzből. Valaki átnézi ott a
papírokat, akkor kiderül, hogy valójában
nem, hanem az egyik tanítási fázis volt
7 millió dollár, és még azon kívül egy
pár 10 milliót elégettek ide-oda. De mi
nem gondolhatjuk komolyan, hogy
Romániában lesz egy magántőkebbefektető,
aki több 10 millió dollárt esz egy román
cégbe. Európában már elképzelhető lenne,
de itt egyáltalán nincs meg az a
kultúra, hogy mondjuk egy egy dán
befektető nézzen román, olasz satöbbi
projektekre úgy, hogy az nem kerül
hozzá. Egy utolsó gondolat ide. Én még
régen volt egy olyan projektem, amivel
kerestem befektetőket így Európába. És
Dánielában pont voltam egy egy
eseményen, ahol bemutattuk a projektet,
és ott nagyon szépen elmondták a Dán
befektetők, hogy ők kíváncsiak, meg
érdekes, meg izgalmas a technológia, de
minden esetben alapelvárás, hogy azonnal
Dániába kell vinni a céget, ott kell
bejegyezni, hogy ők a Dán jogrendszerrel
legyenek védve a pénzükkel, és igazából
ők nem is pedig az Európai jogrendszer
annyiban nem tér el ettől a történettől,
azt mondták, hogy ők már abban sem,
tehát hogy az EU szabályozás neki már
nem ad annyi biztonságot, hogy
kihelyezzék a pénzüket. Ha te tőlük
kéred a befektetést, akkor az a minimum,
hogy Dánielába viszed a céget. Na most
amikor ilyen világ van, akkor ilyen
fragmentált részből nem várható, hogy
ekkora befektetések összejönnek.
>> Hm. Őszintén nem gondoltam még erre,
hogy a tőzsde ennyire befolyásolja az
innovációt, pedig teljesen logikus. Ö
igen. És most akkor át is térhetünk arra
a következő témára, ami ami ugyancsak
foglalkoztat, hogy valójában most ez az
egész AI hullám, ez valójában egy hard
fejlesztési hullám volt. Tehát elértünk
egy olyan szintre, amikor elég olcsóvá
vált a a betanítás, és elég eléggé
iskálázhatóvá vált maga a neurális
hálónak a mérete, hogy hogy átlépjünk
egy egy határvonalat. És ebből úgy néz
ki, hogy most az Nvidia lett a győztes.
Hatalmasat ugrott a tőzsdén. És úgy
felmerül bennem a kérdés, hogy vajon
most monopolhelyzetben van az Nvidia?
Láttok még más olyan hardware céget,
amelyik felveszi a versenyt az
Nvidiával, vagy fel fogja tudni venni a
versenyt? Hát itt azért az Nvidia
esetében van egy mondjuk úgy, hogy
szerencsés egybeesés, hogy pont
az a megközelítés, illetve az a
technológia, ami egyébként fontos volt,
hogy mondjuk számítógépes
grafikában felgyorsítsa és
párhuzamosítsa a
számítások számítások elvégzés.
>> Most a játékfejlesztésre gondolsz, nem?
Meg a játék meg mindenféle. Hát is így
van. az
az a a az pont jó volt arra is, hogy
hogy például gépi tanulásban, neurális
hálók tanításában alkalmazni lehesse.
Tehát ilyen szempontból nekik van egy
egy lépéselőnyük. Ö és
most, hogy
ha mondjuk más
akár processzorgártókkal
hasonlítjuk össze, azért nem
nem biztos, hogy egy általános célú
processzort, gyártó nagy vállalat
most per pillanat versenyezni tud, de
hogy hosszú távon, hogy tud-e az a az a
kérdés inkább, hogy ez hogy hogy akar-e,
hogy hogyha igen, hogyha ebbe lát
potenciált, akkor Akkor akkor szerintem
nem feltétlenül van ez hosszú távon is
kőbevés ez az Nvidia monopólium.
Sándorát pár kiegészítést tennék hozzá.
A az egyik az az, hogy az Nvidiának volt
egy olyan nagy előnye, hogy a a
vezetőjük az egy nagyon vizionárius
alak. Hogyha valaki visszanézi, akkor
elég sok mindent meg lehet nézni akár
10-15 évvel ezelőttől, hogy miről
beszélt ö a a vezetőjük. És az egyik
veszőparipálya az volt, amivel amúgy
igazából elhajtották minden ilyen
processzortervező meggyártó cégtől, az
az, hogy ő ilyen hardvergyorsít
számításban hitt. Tehát ő azt gondolta,
hogy a hardvert lehet olyanra csinálni,
hogy attól legyen gyorsabb a számítás.
Nefek az algoritmusokban kell mindig
gondolkodni, egyszerűen skálázni,
ügyesebbre kell tenni a hardvert. És
ahogy Kares is mondta, ennek az ő
részéről a fő motivációja az a
számítógépes grafika volt. Tehát
játékfejlesztés, videórenderelés,
Hollywoodban az Avatárra, hogyha valaki
emlékszik, akkor ott elmondták, hogy
hány hétig, hónapig ketyegtek a a
számítógépek. Na ők ezt ő ezt akarta
gyorsítani. AI alapú gyorsítása, tehát
akkor még nem nyelv modellekről hanem
kismest neurális hálókkal, rövid
mesterséges intelligenciákkal próbálták
gyorsítani a számítást, előre kitalálni,
hogy mit kéne kiszámítani és nem
kiszámítani, hanem megtippelni az
eredményt. Nagyon szép technológiáik
vannak. Na, ezeket ők mind beleépítették
a hardvébe. És az valóban egy szerencsés
egybeesés, hogy pont azok a típusú
számítások, mátrixműveletek, lineáris
algébra egyebek, ami ahhoz kell, hogy
számítóképes grafikát csináljunk, az
pont ugyanaz, mint ami a mesterséges
intelligenciához kell. By the way,
azért, mert a matematika az mindenhol
ott van. Úgyhogy azt is javaslom a
hallgatóknak, hogy tanulják, de hogy
ebbe az irányba ők nagyon elmentek. És a
másik, ami nagyon fontos összetevője,
hogy minden, ami az ő grafikus
kártyáikon fut, ez egy úgynevezett kuda
programozási nyelven fejlesztik az
emberek. Ami viszont az Nvidiának egy
sajátja, az egy saját technológia, ami
nem nyitott. Tehát hogyha valaki Kudában
programoz, akkor az csak Nvidia
hardweren fog futni. És van egy ilyen
technológiai bezártság, hogy az Nvidia
az elején, amikor ezt megcsinálta, és
kijött a Kudával, hogy a grafikus
kártyáit általános célulan lehessen
programozni. Tehát ne csak arra, hogy
kis háromszögeket meg színeket rendeljen
képernyőre, hanem mondjuk pénzügyi
árfolyamokat számoljon és egyebeket
csináljon. Ők amikor ezt kihozták,
kellett legalább egy fél évtized, mire
más gyártók vagy nyitott standardok
megjelentek ugyanerre a feladatra. Ebben
az időszakban viszont azvid annyival
hatékonyabb lett, hogyha mondjuk ma
megnézünk egy egy Open Seal, vagy egy
vagy egy vulkán, vagy egyéb típusú
technológiát, ami ugyanezt célozza,
akkor van egy 20-30%-os performancia
lemaradásuk. Ezek egyfelől azért vannak,
mert később indultak, másfelől azért,
mert általános célúak, tehát ugyanúgy
futnak egy Intelprocesszoron, mint egy
Nvidám, mint máshol. De ez a 20-30%, ez
bődületesen sok. Tehát amikor valaki azt
mondja, hogy 7 millió euróba kerül nekem
egy modellnek a tanítása, hogy egyből
hirtelen 10 millió lesz, az egy nem
elfogadható költség. És emiatt
gyakorlatilag az történik, hogy minden
az Nvidia hardverére épül. Az összes
technológia Nvidia specifikus kuda
kódokban van megírva. Tehát még az sem,
ha most hirtelen az AMD kijönne egy
15%-al hatékonyabb processzorral, ami
bődületes szám, vagy nem fognak kijönni
15%-a hatékonyabb processzorral, akkor
sem állná senki
AMD kódokra, mert újra kéne írni az
összes szoftvert satöbbi. Tehát, hogy
ilyen szempontból van egy nagyon erős
ilyen szimbiózis, és ezt nagyon ügyesen
kihasználják az Nvidiánál. Ez ezt meg
kell hagyni, hogy ez egy nagyon nagy
előnyük volt nekik.
Azt amúgy elképzelhetőnek tartjátok,
hogy egyszer annyira kevés hardware
legyen majd az a nagynyelvi modelleknek
az igénye, hogy egy telefonon is
elfusson egy komplex nagynyelvi modell.
>> Én ebben szinte biztos vagyok, hogy hát
a a kérdés az, hogy mit jelent, hogy
komplex nagynyelvi modell, meg
>> hát egy nem tudom 30 milliárd
paraméteres, hogy most
>> egyfelől nagy valg nincs annyi
paraméterre szükség, tehát azt azt a
nagyon komoly kutatások vannak abban. És
ameddig a az Openi AI nem kezdte el ezt
a hiperskálázását a nyelv modelleknek,
igazából arról szólt nagyon sok AI
kutatás, hogy hogyan lehet piciben,
hatékonyan, egyszerre a specifikus
AI-okat trénelni. És ott mindenki arról
beszélt, hogy telefonon akarjuk
futtatni, kicsiben akarjuk futtatni.
Most velünk elhitetik, hogy igazából ez
ingyen van, mert belépünk a chat GPT-be,
beírjuk és jön kijön a válasz. Csak az
nincs ott, hogy a túlsoldalon azért
valaki mennyit fizet. Ez egy masszívan
veszteséges üzlet jelenleg. Tehát
valahol az elején mondtad, hogy vajon
hol fog megállni, majd amikor piaci áron
kell beárazni minden tokent, amit
elégetünk ezekkel az AI-okkal, akkor
majd nem fogjuk kérni a mindenféle
baromságainkat. Tehát a mi nap láttam
egy videót,
egy cég szerette volna promózni magát,
és akkor megkérte az AÁt-t, hogy
légyszíves csinálj nekem egy olyan
videót, ahol egy zenekar, a céglogója a
háttérben a zenek a cégről énekel, és az
AI képességeiről egy ilyen metálos
zenében előadja magát, és egy nagyon
frankó videó. Énekelnek emberek,
csápolnak a videóban. Tehát nagyon jól
néz ki,
ameddig ez ingyen volt. De hogyha most
én azt mondanám, hogy oké, de így 40 így
ilyen videónak mondjuk 1000 euró a
legenerálási költsége, akkor és mit
tudom én egy jó gegszer meg lehet
osztani a Facebookon, akkor már nem
kérném. Tehát hogy majd az lesz, hogy
amikor ez piacilag beárazódik, akkor ez
egy nagyon más beszélgetés lesz.
Szerintem nagyon aktív kutatások lesznek
arra, hogy valamilyen szinten, mert hány
olyan usecase van, ahol egyszerre kell
felidézni a Petőfi összest, és azt is
megmondani, hogy a kvantumfizikának hogy
működnek a képletei. Tehát ez ez nincs
ilyen nagy általános igény. Amint tudni
fogjuk, hogy mire kell, össze fogják
annyira húzni a modellt. Ott fog lenni,
ott lesz a telefonunkban, lesz egy
alkalmazás, ahol mit tudom én,
egészséges ételeket meg recepteket
akarunk csinálni. Az az alkalmazás az
fog tudni egy olyan Nát-t használni, ott
lesz a telefonokban, vagy beépítve, vagy
az alkalmazáshoz, ami oda már el fog
férni. Én ebben szinte biztos vagyok,
hogy ez a kezünkön, óránkon,
pacemakerekben mindenhol ott lesz majd.
>> Viszont, hogyha egy stúdiót kéne
felbéreljünk, hogy le forgassuk azt a
pillanatot, amikor a cég logója mögött
egy egész zenekar
zenél, az az nem 1000 dollár lesz, hanem
sok ezer vagy sok 10000 dollár.
>> Ez így van, de valószínűleg 100-nál
többet nem ér az egész. Tehát, hogy a az
egyik megoldás sem gazdaságilag
racionális. Most az van, hogy van a a
szinte ingyen megoldás, és az majdnem
szinte mindenre gazdaságilag racionális.
Ez aztán ez ki fog kopni. Tehát amint
beállítjuk pénzügyileg rentabilis az
egészet, akkor az fog történni, hogy
ezek az ilyen fölösleges jus készek,
ezek ezek elmennek majd. Igen. A
visszatérve magához a a programozáshoz,
a tegnapi demóban, amit a amúgy a chat
GPT-nek a fejlesztőkhöz szánt
frissítésében láttam, konkrétan az
történt, ugye a hallgatóknak elmondom,
hogy konkrétan az egyik demó hogyan
nézett ki. élőben az egyik a aikát,
ami a a nézőközönség fele nézett, ott
helyben meg írtak egy programot, vagyis
egy megkérte a chat GPT-t, hogy írjon
egy programot, amelyik ezt a kamerát
működteti, tehát lehetett mozgatni és a
fényeket be tudta kapcsolni, valamint
hozzáírt egy olyan megoldást, hogy egy
ilyen Nintendo konzolból lehessen
irányítani, valamint egy voice alapú,
tehát egy ilyen szöveges alapú
megoldást, hogy utána pedig beszél
beszélni is tudjon hozzá, és valamint
élőben programozta. Tehát ez volt a
legmegdöbbentőbb számomra, hogy már nem
le kellett forgatni, hanem beszélt az
alkalmazáshoz és önmagát forgatta le és
változtatta az az alkalmazás. És úgy
miután meghallgattam ezt a ezt a részt,
olyan kettős érzés volt bennem. Egyrészt
az, hogy ez most biztos, hogy minimum
heteket vett volna igénybe valakinek,
aki megnézi, hogy a kamerának a a az
illesztőprogramja hogyan működik. ö hogy
hogy az a felületet, a UI felületet
elkészíti, beköt mindent és és utána
tesztel, és utána aztán működőképes
lesz. Ez ez percekre rövidült le. Ez az
egyik, tehát ez a pozitív oldal. A másik
oldalon pedig az, hogyha most ebbe a
szoftverbe valahol van egy bug, vajon
mennyi esélyem van nekem kijavítani azt
a bugot, hogyha ha heteket kellett volna
igénybe vegyem, hogy megértsem magát az
architektúrát.
A harmadik pedig az, hogy rendben, de
akkor is nagyon gyorsan legenerálta.
Tehát hogyha ehhez hasonló dolgokat
tudunk generálni, és akkor akkor mi lesz
a programozás jövé? Mennyire kell érteni
magához az algoritmikához? Mennyire kell
érteni magához a a annak annak, ami ami
ami a mi az a komplex fogasrendszer, ami
mögötte van? Úgyhogy tényleg így így
hintáztam magamban, és bizonyos
szempontból most is így így nézem, hogy
hova kell most dőln, mert maga a demó
után ez a kettős érzés, gyanítom nem
csak bennem volt, hanem hanem a a
hallgatók egy zömében, akik azon
gondolkoznak rendben, akkor most azzal a
tudással, amit éveken keresztül
felszedtem, most mit kezdjek? Van még a
full stacknek értelme? Van még a
különböző programozási nyelveknek
értelme? Van a ami engem szenorrá tett,
tegyük fel, és 10 éven keresztül
begyakoroltam, és meg tudok írni egy
chron jobot. ö anélkül, hogy csalnék és
megnézném az interneten, hogy hogyan
kell ezt pontosan megcsinálni. Ez egy
igazi érték még manapság. Úgyhogy egy
kicsit még beszélgetnék erről, mert mert
az az érzésem, hogy itt itt valami jön,
csak nem tudom, hogy mennyire valós.
>> Ühüm.
Ha megengeded, közelítsük meg egy kicsit
másik oldalról. Gondoltál bele abba,
hogy mennyi tudásra volt neked szükséged
ahhoz, hogy azt a tegnapi videót
értsed, tudjad értékelni és ezek a
kérdések megfogalmazódjanak?
>> Tehát, hogy mennyi tudás szükséges
ahhoz, hogy ez a filmől? Igen. Tehát,
hogy Igen.
>> Tehát azokat a fogalmakat, amiket ő
amikkel ők ott operáltak, hogy akkor
>> igen,
>> mert hogy az nem kevés. És mennyi
tudásra volt neki szüksége, aki ezt a
ezt a demótot tényleg helyben
összerakta. Egyrészt ahhoz, hogy meg
tudja fogalmazni az AI-nak, hogy mit
szeretne, elég pontosan ahhoz, hogy
abból lehetőleg egy jó output süljön ki.
utána, hogy tudja úgymond
értelmezni
és
akár adott esetben alakítani azt, amit
amit eredményként kapott,
akár még az egyszerűbb demóknál vagy
példáknál is, hogy a különböző
eredmények közül tudjon kiválasztani,
ahhoz ő kellett lássa, hogy melyik a
melyik a jobb ezek között. Tehát, hogy
ez lenne egy válasz, hogy hogy
>> meg azért ő is elmondta a háttérben,
hogy előre előkészítette az NPM
packageeket, azok letöltötte és
összerakta, hogy azért ne ott helybe
keljen, megvárja, amik
>> ezzel kicsit visszakan visszakanyarodva
ez a ez az eszköz, tehát ezzel az
eszközzel ő tényleg percek alatt össze
tudott rakni egy egy aránylag nagy
komplexitású történetet, de ehhez neki
rengeteg háttértudásra volt szüksége
ahhoz, hogy ezt ezt megtegye. Tehát ez
lenne az egyik megközelítés, amit
mondanék. A másik megközelítés az pedig
ugye el előbb mondtad azt, hogy hogy
hogy gyakorlatilag azért is következett
be hirtelen ez a robbanásszerű
fejlődés a a mesterséges intelligencia a
házatáján, mert ugye a hardver
eszközeink ezt már ezt már lehetővé
tennék. Ezt hozzátenném, hogy hogy igen.
És adatunk is volt, mert ugye ahogy
többször elhangzott a mesterséges
intelligencia az adatok nélkül vak.
Tehát volt egy pillanat, amikor már
rendelkezésünkre állt elegendő
mennyiségű adat, hogy ténylegesen ezeket
a gépi tanulási modelleket a már
rendelkezésünkre álló hardvereszközökön
megfelelő hatékonysággal tudjuk tudjuk
tanítani. De ez az AI, ez nem azóta van
belünk, tehát erről talán már együtt is
sokat beszélgettünk. akár még egy másik
rész keretében is, hogy igazából
gyakorlatilag a mesterséges
intelligencia kutatások azok
tulajdonképpen egyidősek a
számítástechnik vagy mondhatjuk azt,
hogy egyítősek a számítástechnikai
kutatásokkal.
azoknak a modelleknek, amik amiken
alapulnak a mai
hiperszuper, akár nagynyelvű modellek,
akár más gép tanulási módszerek, ezeknek
ezeknek a matematikai alapjai, ezek
le voltak téve jó ideje már a múlt
században. És
nagyon a a vicc az, hogy hogy vagy
vicces az, hogy itt nagyon sok minden
nem változik, tehát hogy sem a
matematikai háttér szempontjából, sem
mondjuk a ha tovább lépünk, akkor az
algoritmika szempontjából, tehát hogy
hogy azt mondjuk, hogy az informatika,
ezt régóta mondjuk, nem csak az AI
kontextusában, hogy a az informatika az
rendkívül dinamikusan fejlődik, hogy
hogy nehéz tartani a lépést, mert hogy
minden nap változik valami, jelennek meg
új dolgok, és ez ez igaz. jó részt
bizonyos területeken, de másik oldalon a
nem tudom, a régi több évtizedde kiadott
algoritmika könyvben leírtak, azok
ugyanúgy igazak és érvényesek ma is,
mint ahogy érvényesek voltak, érvényesek
voltak akkor. Hát a a válasz az itt itt
csatlakozom Sándorhoz, aki előbb
javasolta, hogy a matematikát
tanulni kell, hogy
hogy
hogy Igen, tehát az tehát a
az, hogy hogy egy igazából bármelyik
szakmában érvényesülni tudjunk, ahhoz
annak a
az ah szakmát meg kell tanuljuk, és
annak a a az alapjait nagyon jól el kell
sajátítsuk, hogy utána bármit rá tudjunk
rá tudjunk építeni.
Az AIAL kontextusában pedig ami
ami akár ami egyébként oktatás
szempontból kihívás ugye egy
csapdahelyzet lehet, hogyha úgymond
elkényelmesedünk, a kényelemben ugye
könnyű beleszokni, és akkor azt
gondoljuk, hogy attól, mert ezek a ezek
az eszközök
nem tudom, sokszor kiváltják a
gondolkodásunkat,
helyettünk gondolkodnak, vagy legalábbis
látszólag. Ez azt jelenti, hogy akkor
nekünk kevesebbet kell tudni. A helyzet
az, hogy nem, tehát nekünk többet kell
tudjunk, hogyha mi érvényesülni akarunk,
és akarjuk tudni megfelelő módon
használni ezeket a ezeket az eszközöket.
Tehát nem kevesebb, hanem ez több
>> Igen. Itt van egy két paradoxom tényleg,
mert a az ahhoz szokott hozzá úgy az
oktatási rendszerünk, mind a világunk,
hogy eredményeket produkálunk és mert
mert az eredmények, ha látjuk az
eredményeket, akkor feltételezzük, hogy
azt a azon a folyamaton az a személy
végigment, hogy el tudja írni azokat az
eredményeket. Viszont most ez az AI is
eredményeket produkál, megdöbbentő
eredményeket, egy essét, egy egy levelet
megír helyettünk, most már kódol is
helyettünk, és már nem feltételezhetjük,
hogy ezt az egész folyamatot bejárta az
a személy, aki azt az eredményt elérte.
Tehát gyakorlatilag a tudása nem lett
több, azáltal ugyanazt az eredményt
felmutatja, mint ezelőtt tegyük fel öt
évvel, amikor nem voltak ezek az
eszközök, és feltételezhettük, hogy ha
ezt meg tudod csinálni, akkor vagy
másoltad nyilván, vagy vagy
végigdolgoztad ezt az egészet, de
gyakorlatilag pillanatok alatt lehetett
látni, hogy most is lehet látni, hogy
valaki tud-e angolul például, vagy nem
tud angolul. Tehát, hogy hogy amikor
megszólal, hiába egy tökéletes angolságú
emailt ír, ugye valójában a háttérbe
feltételezhetjük, hogy lehet, hogy egy
szót sem tud angolul a a nagy nyelvi
modell miatt, és hogy ilyen szempontból
talán egy új ébredésre van szüksége az
oktatási
intézményeknek is, meg valójában a
diákoknak is, hogy egyrészt hogyan
mérjük azt, amit eddig mértünk és
eredményeket mértünk, most valahogy a
folyamatot kellene mérni. Másrészt,
másrészt pedig diák szempontjából is
mélyen megérteni azt, hogy kit csapunk
be, hogyha eredményeket hozunk, és a
folyamaton nem megyünk végig, tehát nem
izzadjuk végig azt a feladatot, ami bár
triviálisnak tűnik, és a végén azt
mondjuk, hogy hát ezt öt perc alatt
megírtam a chat GPT-vel. Úgy se az a
fontos, hogy meglegyen öt perc alatt,
hanem az a fontos, hogy végigizzadjam
azt a hetet, ameddig megértem, hogy
hogyan jut el, hogyan jutok el annak a
végére.
>> Hát ez teljesen egyértelmű. A
gyakorlatilag én nem láttam a
különbséget aközött, hogy egy házi
feladat úgy adok be, hogy lemásolom a
kollégáról, vagy megkérdezem a chat
GPT-t, ő kiírja a prontot, és azt
másolom le. Tehát ez ugyanúgy másolás.
Ami a nagy különbség, az az, hogy eddig
a másolás nem volt hatékonyan
technológiailag támogatva. Tehát
mondjuk, ha visszaemlékszek én az
egyetemi tanulmányaimra, ha megkaptunk
mondjuk a matematikus képzésben házi
feladatot, akkor egyfelől volt annyi
szerencsémünk, hogy mondjuk öten voltunk
az éfolyamon és személyre szabadott házi
feladatot kaptunk, úgyhogy esélyünk se
volt senkitől másolni. Ha pedig esetleg
közös volt, volt az az öt ember, akit
tudtam, hogy meg tudok kérdezni, ott
tanár is látta, hogy kiket lehet
megkérdezni. Tehát nem volt egyszerű az
előző évfolyamoktól például ugyanazokat
a házikat lehet már nem kaptuk meg,
tehát nem tudtuk ilyen nagyon könnyedén
másolni. Most pedig a világ összes
tudása ott van a chat GPT-ben. Ha én
másolni akarok, akkor meg tudom
kérdezni, hogyha nem tudom Timbuktubba
vagy egyetemen ez a feladat fel volt
adva ezelőtt 10 évvel, és én behíom a
feladatot a prontba, meg fogom kapni a
megoldást. De ez ugyanolyan másolás.
Tehát a diákok az, hogy az a diák, aki
eddig nem másolt, mert azt mondta, hogy
magának akar tanulni, az ha GPT
használja, max annyit kell megugorjon
szellemileg, hogy rájöjjön, hogy ez is
pont olyan másolás, amit oda
visszakapcsolnék, hogy hogy
kell-e nekünk az, vagy vagy
miért kell nekünk átizzadni ezen a
folyamaton magunkat, és hogy fogjuk ezt
az oktatási rendszerbe beépíteni.
Nag elég hangosita van arról, hogy itt
most külön szabályozások kellenek és
nagyon meg kell ugrani ezeket a
szinteket, hogy most majd az AI-ra
minden egyetem mondjon valamit, meg kell
szabályozni. Én úgy vagyok vele, hogy a
a közösség ezt is megugrotta. Nagyon
régóta vannak számológépeink. Soha senki
nem kérdőjelezte meg, hogy miért kell a
szorzótáblát tanítani. Nem tudom most
hányadik osztályban tanítják a
szorzótáblát, de hogy én nem halljuk az
emberektől, hogy már nem kell
szórzótáblát tanítani. Egyszerűen
eljutottak oda, hogy igen, van egy
tudás, amit maximálisan kiváltottunk
gépekkel, mégis meg akarjuk tanítani a
gyermekeinknek. Ezt ugyanezt a szintet
kell megugrani. Az egyetemen is van egy
tudás. Fordiklust írni most már tud a
gép is nagyon egyszerűen, de ez egy
olyan tudás, amit az embernek meg kell
ugr meg kell tanulni, át kell élni,
végig kell küzdeni ahhoz, hogy aztán
később menjen. Lesz soha nem fogja
csinálni, mert nem tudom, négyszámjegyű
számokat szerintem senki nem szóz
papíron valójában, de az iskolában mégis
kérjük, ha csinálják. És szerintem van
egy elég széles konszenzus a oktatással
foglalkozó körében, hogy ezt nem kéne
kivenni az oktatási programból. Tehát,
hogy ide el kell jusson majd a felső
oktatás is. E szerintem ez ez meg fog
történni. Két dologra szeretnék még
kicsit visszautalni. Az egyik az, hogy a
az open Devd mondtad ezt a
kamerairányítós demót, és ez pont
ugyanaz a szituáció, mint amiről
beszéltem a a beszélgetés elején, a
80%-os demo effektus. Tehát arra nagyon
jó volt, hogy ő ott azt a kameráját
abban a helyzetben ezt irányítsa. De
mikor lesz ebből termék? Akkor lesz
ebből termék. Tehát egy olyan, amiért
pénzt kapsz, amikor olyan szolgáltatást
csinálsz, hogy ki tudod tenni a netre,
el tudod adni azt mondani, hogy uram, ha
maga fizet nekem 100 eur-t és letölti
ezt a szoftvert, akkor a saját kameráját
fogja tudni irányítani a saját
rendezvényén. Nagyon cuccos lesz. Igen
ám, de ehhez az összes kameratípust
ismerni kell, ehhez az összes konzol
típust ismerni kell, a hálózathoz
csatlakozni kell valahoz. Az IT
biztonsági kérdések az egész AI
környékén egy egy olyan ilyen
kígyófészek, amibe senki nem mer
belenyúlni. Tehát képzeljük el azt, hogy
ha én három perc alatt meg tudom oldani,
hogy ahhoz a kamerához én csatlakoztam
és irányítottam, akkor más is meg tudja
oldani, hogy három percal csatlakozzon
és irányítsa. Tehát, hogy a háttérbe itt
sok minden nem volt elmondva, a nyakam
teszem rá, hogy én ha ott kint a
folyósón vagyok, és ugyanezt a
technológiát ismerem, én nem tudtam
volna azt a kamerát irányítani.
Elmondta az előadó is, hogy nagyon sokat
készítették elő ezt a demót. Nyilván egy
ilyen rendezvényen nem fér bele, hogy
ott improvizáljanak, de ha azt sok órát
összerakjuk, akkor is van egy 80%-os
demójuk. Ebből míg eljutunk oda, hogy
egy piacilag életképes embereknek
eladható alkalmazás legyen, az egy
nagyon nagy erőfeszítés. Amit én látok
Kihút, ami egy ilyen kompromisszum ebben
a történetben, ezek az ilyen
egyszemélyes eldobható feladatok. Tehát
megyek valahova, talán te mondtad, hogy
valahol kellett neked egy gyors számláló
egy képernyőn, és akkor gyorsan tudsz
mondani egy olyan kis program, hogy
légyszíves generálj nekem egy olyan
alkalmazást, ami full screenen fut és
nem tudom 5 órától visszafele számol
másodpercenként legenerálja, eldobom,
mert gazdaságilag megérte, hogy ott
neked gyorsan egy ilyen legyen, és nem
akartad 100%-os nem akartad, hogy minden
időzónában, mindenféle eszközön, minden
méretben ilyenolyan csilivili
funkciókal, bejelentkezéssel, izével
hozzéval menjen. Akartál egy kicsi
valami demócskát magadnak. Erre jó.
tovább fejleszteni ezt nem olyan
egyszerű. És nekem a fejemben az van,
hogy a a legnagyobb különbség aközött,
hogy a az AI-t mikor fog mikortól fogjuk
tudni, mint olyan dolog használni, amire
amit nem kell értsük, hogy mit csinál,
az akkor lesz, amikor egy másik
absztrakció szinten fog gondolkodni,
mint mi. Addig, ameddig az AI ugyanazon
a programozási nyelven generálja a
kódját és a szoftvert, mind amit amúgy
mi is értünk, és ugye mi kell
kijavítsuk, meg mi kell javítgassuk,
addig ez a dolog szerintem egyszerűen
nem működhet. Tehát ma ha valaki mondjuk
visszatekint, hogy hogyan programoztunk
a régi idők óta, volt ugye gépi
nyelvben, asszemblerben programoztunk,
aztán lettek fejlettebb nyelvek, aztán
lettek még fejlettebb nyelvek, de ezek
mind úgy épülnek, főleg, hogyha egyik
épít a másikra, hogy az alatta levő
réteg az egy 100%-osan megbízható,
determinisztikus, precíz, mérnöki
eszköz. Ha
jelenleg ez nem igaz, tehát nem tudjuk
azt mondani, hogy az AI-nak mi valami
prontot fent leírunk, és a 100%-ban
leképeződik valami a mi mondásunk
valamire, ami a gépen fut. Ameddig ez
nem teljesül, és már meg is beszéltük,
hogy végül is a a nyelvi modellek ezt
nem fogják soha hozni, addig ez a az
abstrakció szint, ez nem válik el.
Ugyanazon a szinten beszélgetünk mi,
mint az AI. És ez innentől kezdve azt
jelenti, hogy nekünk kell érteni, tehát
hogy minden technológia az AI használ,
nekünk értenünk kell, mert mert ha
elrontja, ki kell javítsuk. És ami egy
másik ilyen nagy kerékkötője az egész
dolognak, a szociver fejlesztésben van
egy olyan kifejezés, hogy techp, ami
ilyen technikai adósságot jelent
gyakorlatilag. Ez arról szól, hogy a
gyors haladás érdekében időnként hozunk
kompromisszumokat a fejlesztésben,
amiket feljegyzünk magunknak, és azokat
a kompromisszumokat időnként
megpróbáljuk kivasalni, rendbe tenni a
rendszert magunk körül. Na most ez az AI
által generált szoftverfejlesztés, ez
gyakorlatilag egy futószallagú ilyen
technológia adósság gyár, amivel az
történik, hogy amikor egyszer valahol
probléma lesz, nem tudom, az egyik
legjobban fető fizető kliensünk egyszer
szól, hogy nem tudom, Taiwan van egy
ügyfele, akihez feltelepítette a
telefoná telefonjára szoftvert, nem
működik. És most beperelt minket 1
millió dollárra, mert valami garanciánk
valahol ott volt, és izé hozzé. És akkor
most mit csinálunk? Tehát mondhatjuk egy
fejlesztőnek, hogy légys javítsd meg azt
a dolgot, de ő elkezd belenézni. És a
technikai adóságnak az a természetes
tulajdonsága, hogyha ezt felgyűlik,
akkor nagyon gyorsan emelkedik a
javítási költsége. Tehát ha mi öt-h évig
nem foglalkozunk azzal, hogy a
csapatunkban legyen szaktudás, aki
pontosan érti a szoftvernek minden
rezdülését, minden kódsorát,
és az a kódsorok olyanok, hogy nem
tekinthetünk rájuk 100%-os
megbízhatóságúként,
akkor az nagyon-nagyon csúnyán arcul fog
minket ütni később, hogy amikor majd
odakeveredünk. Úgyhogy ez szerintem ez
lesz majd egy olyan dolog. És ebbe
nagyon sokan bele is futnak szerintem,
tehát elindítják a kis alkalmazásukat.
nagyon jól működik tesztesetben,
tesztkörnyezetben, egy-két userrel, és
akkor azt mondja, jó, skálázzuk ki,
próbáljuk meg 10 millió emberrel, és
akkor minden recseg, ropog, és azt se
tudja, hogy hova nyúljon, és lehet, hogy
az alapjaitól kell mindent újra
csinálni, mert valójában nem olyan
olyanra sikerült az egész. Úgyhogy én
szerintem itt itt itt ebbe a
demóeffektus történetbe ebbe beleakadtak
szerintem az openjánál, és ami nem gond,
mert ők egy demót kellett csináljanak.
Tehát tudod, tökéletes volt, de piacira
piacra kivezethető szolgáltatást az
szerintem még nagyon-nagyon messze volt
onnan. Igen, meg van egy olyan aspektusa
is, amúgy ezekkel mind egyetértek, van
egy olyan aspektusa is, hogy
túlbecsöljük az AI-nak a a
termékét, tehát a magát azt, hogy mit
termel az AI. Most mondok egy példát. Az
egyik kliensünk
közösségi médiára posztokat gyárt AI
által, és automatizálja a posztgyártást.
Nagyon jó ötlet. Viszont utána azon
gondolkoztam, hogy tényleg nagyon
lerövidíti azt a marketing
tevékenységet, amit valaki bele kell
fektessen ahhoz, hogy egy adott
terméknek az összes közösségi médián
megjelen a megjelenését
menedzseli. Viszont utána arra
gondoltam, hogy én én valóban mint fel
mint mint olvasó szeretném használni,
vagyis szeretném olvasni azokat az AI
által generált posztokat. Tehát én én
nem szeretek AI által generált
szövegeket olvasni. Amiatt, mert steril,
amiatt, mert mert precíz, amiatt, mert
valahol nem nem emberi. Tehát érzem azt,
hogy olyan nem emberi. És olvastam utána
egy idézetet, hogy a diákok a CV-jüket
AI-jal iríratják meg, a HR AI-jal
olvastatja el, és senkit nem
alkalmaznak. Úgyhogy van van egy ilyen
ilyen iróniája ennek az egésznek.
Emlékszem, amikor amikor a chat GPT
3.5-ös megjelent rá egy hetekkel
megjelent egy ilyen hirdetés, hogy
generáltassak 10 dollárér AI könyvet,
csak írjam le, hogy mit akarok abba a
könyvbe. Mármint a az alapgondolatokat ő
kigenerálja, jegyzeteket átolvasom és
lehet az Amazonon árulni. És azon
gondolkoztam, hogy ez nem pont a lényeg
lényegét veszi el a könyvírásnak. Tehát
amikor valaki beleftet egy most én nem
olvasok túl gyorsan, lehet, hogy egy
hetet beleftetek egy könyvbe, hogy
elolvassam azt a könyvet. tényleg egy
hetet el akarok tölteni valamivel, ami
AI által volt generálva. Úgyhogy
valószínűleg AI-jal fogom elolvastatni
azt a könyvet és hogy hogy kezd egy
ilyen ilyen kannibalizmus történni,
amikor önmagát eszi az AI, amikor azt az
információt fogja feldolgozni, amit
amúgy is ő generált. És és lesz egy
ilyen furcsa paradoxon, amit amúgy te is
említettél, hogy hogy újat nem hoz.
Nem tudom, ezzel kapcsolatban van-e
valami
>> van. Igen. Tehát, hogy a van egy
fogalom, ha valaki tanul információ
elméletet távközlésben, informatikában,
ez egy elég fontos dolog. Van egy olyan
mérőszám, amit úgy hívnak, hogy
információs sűrűség, ami az adott
adatmennyiségben méri, hogy mennyi az az
információ, ami ami ott valójában
újdonság. Tehát ha van egy hosszú
sorozatunk 1500 nullából, az ugyan 1500
hosszú, de csak nullák vannak benne. Az
valójában egy nulla.
>> Tehát hogyha most akarunk egy analógiát
mondani, egy nicét olvasni, nem ugyanaz,
mint egy szappanoperát meghallgatni.
Tehát, hogy mennyi információ íg van így
is lehets ami a lényeges, hogy hogy a
chat GPT is és minden más nyelv modell,
az valójában csak egy transzformátor,
egy ez a a promból is ugye én beírok
valamit, ő ebből nyilván mellé tesz
kontextusból információkat, meg amiket
tanult a világból, és abból ki kihoz
valamit, de információt ő nem tud
teremteni. Tehát én amit beteszek, plusz
ami van a világban, ebből fog kijönni
az, ami van kívül. Most, hogyha az én
promptom egy üres, egy nulla hosszú
karakterlánc, akkor nyilván nem fog
semmit csinálni belőle. abban nagyon
ügyesek, hogy én leírom egy mondatban,
hogy mit akarok, és akkor ő egész jól
kitalál mellé sok mindent, és a a
világságából kicsit kiegészíti,
de információt ő tőlem a fejem, tehát ő
azt tudja kitalálni, hogy mások ilyen
környezetben miket mondtak, de azt, hogy
én speciel mit akarnék ott mondani, azt
nyilván nem tudja kitalálni. Most
töltelékszövegnek a generálására ez
nagyon rendben van. Tehát ha leírom,
hogy mit tudom én, Hargitán havazott,
légyszíves írjál 15 bekezdést arról,
hogy milyen gyönyörű egy havas
hegyoldal. Nagyon sok havas hegyoldal
leírás van az interneten, majd csinálj
belőle egy szépet. De ha nekem van egy
speciális élményem, hogy nem tudom egy
katonai kiképző táborban milyen volt,
amikor egy bicskát kellett recsegtessek
a fogam között, és erről mondjuk nem írt
senki soha semmit az interneten, azt ő
nem fogja tudni nekem kiegészíteni, mert
nincs ami alapján. Tehát az van, hogy
amit mi információt nem viszünk be a
rendszerbe, azt nincs ahonnan túlfelő
kijöjjön. A tanulásból nyilván
valamennyi információt szed a a ezek a
mesterséges intelligenciák, de ha valami
igazán újat csinálunk, akkor mindennek a
speciális információtit le kell írni.
Tehát ha egy kamerai irányító rendszert
akarok összerakni és kitalálom, hogy az
én nagy okosságom az pont az, hogy ez a
kamerairányító rendszer úgy működik,
hogy nem tudom a gyűrűlsújam és a
mutatójam közti távolsággal fogom tudni
irányítani ezt a rendszert, mivel ilyet
senki nem csinált, nem lesz elég
elmondani szóban, hogy légyszíves
csinálj egy olyat, ami ennek a két újnak
a távolságával irányítsam, mert a CG GPT
nem fogja tudni, hogy most én arra
gondolok, hogy ha közelebb teszem őket,
vagy 20 fokos szögbe állítom a két
ujamatot egymáshoz, tehát hogy mire
gondolt a költő, amikor ezt leírta, ezt
minden el kell mondani, és oda
keveredünk vissza, hogy mindent precízen
le kell írni, hogy hogy akarod csinálni.
És ezt hívják programozásnak. Tehát,
hogyha valaki egy jó minőségű
programkódot megnéz és beszél angolul,
ma mi is a cégben azt várjuk el, hogyha
én elolvastatom valakivel a kódot, ami
ott van, ő angol nyelvi tudás után
gyakorlatilag mint folyószöveggkel tudja
olvasni a szöveget. Ha nem, akkor
valamit nem jól csináltak a kollégák.
Tehát változóneve, függvénynevek,
satöbbi, satöbbi, az nem jól van
kitalálva.
>> Tehát a kód maga a dokumentáció.
>> Egyfele. Az a dokumentáció, de a másik
az, hogy az egy emberi nyelven olvasott
dokumentáció. Tehát nem az van, hogy x2
= f3 zárójel és 52 szám, hanem the door
should open egyenlő
are all condition satisfied for door
opening satöbbi. Tehát, hogy ez egy
értelmesen angolul leírt szöveg. És
igazából a chgpt ennyit csinál, csak nem
formalizálta a 100%-os hogy kéri a
szöveget, mert kitalálja helyettünk.
Tehát nincsen egy egy ezt egy nagyon
szigorú nyelvi kontextusa meg egy nyelvi
szintaxisa, de ha ez lenne, akkor egy
programozási nyelv lenne. Tehát igazából
ebbe az irányba megyünk és az
információt be kell vinni, amit én nem
írok le precízen, azt ő nem fogja tudni
teljesen kitalálni. Nyilván egy csomó
mindent igen, de ettől függetlenül a
bevitt információból fog kijönni a külső
a kijövő hasznos adat. És amikor valami
nagyon speciálisat akarunk csinálni,
megint a 80%-ra eljutni a 100-ra, akkor
minden egyes kis elágazást el kell
magyarázni majd neki, hogy ezt úgy
csináld, hogy abban az esetben, ha ez a
két feltétel teljesül, de a harmadik
nem, de a negyedik igen, és tegnapelőtt
valami volt. Figyelj légyszíves arra,
hogy ez történjen. És ha te minden ilyen
kis esetet szépen végiggondolsz és
leírsz, akkor ugyanott vagy, mint ahol
eddig voltál. A nagyját azt nyilván
megcsinálta előre, de ugyanazokat a
képességeket igényli majd a befejezés,
mint ami eddig is kellett. Csak a, hogy
is mondjam, a az ilyen alacsonyan logó
almákat, ahogy szokták mondani angolul,
azokat nekem begyűjti, meg a a könnyű
lábmunkát elvégzi, de a a a befejezést,
a finis munkát, amin a legnagyobb érték
van, ugye, hogyha valaki épített házat,
az tudja, hogy nem a téglarakásban van a
pénz, hanem abban, hogy a kis nem tudom,
négy centimes csempét szépen feltegyék.
Na, ott van a a hús a levesbe. Valójában
a szoftverfejlesztésben is ez van, hogy
a finisben van a hús a levesbe, és ahhoz
pont ezeket a dolgokat kell tudni.
Igen, egy nagyon nagyon fontos dologhoz
érkeztünk.
A valójában angolul jobban hangzik, ez a
computation versus comprehension. Tehát
a a gép az számolni tud egy statisztikai
modell, am ami ami a végén egy nagyon
valószínű helyes választ kiad. Viszont
nem érti, hogy ez mi az egy ez ez egy
teljesen emberi dimenzió az értése, a
megértése, az az értelme valaminek.
Márpedig az, hogy miért csináljuk, amit
csinálunk, az egy az az mélyen egy
emberi dolog megérteni, hogy hogyan
kapcsolódik be ez a világban, hogyan
fogom én használni, hogyan fogják
használni a felhasználók, hogyan tudom
ezt ezt eladhatóvá tenni már önmagában
az, hogy eladható valami, az egy
nagyon-nagyon komplex folyamat. És és ez
ez ilyen szempontból engem megnyugtat,
hogy ez nem fog változni. A gép nem
fogja értelmezni, érteni helyettünk,
hogy hogy az, amit csinál, az helyes-e
vagy hely neki minden helyes, amit kiad,
a leghelyesebb, amit csak ki tud adni. A
világgazdasági fórum kiadott most nemrég
egy egy tanulmányt, ez a Future of Job
Markets, hogy hogy ki lesz a jövő,
milyen kvalitásokra lesz szükség ahhoz,
hogy hogy a jövőbeli
munka munkavállaló a lehető
leghatékonyabb és a lehető legikeresebb
legyen. És nyilván az első helyen és a
második helyen ilyen technikai
kvalitások kellenek, tehát az AI
alaptudás meg egy ilyen digitális
általános műveltség, hogy tudjunk
eszközöket használni. De ami nekem
meglepett, és bizonyos szempontból nem
lepett meg, de jól esett olvasni, hogy
hogy ezt látom, a többi nyolc a top
10-ből azok mind ilyen ilyen szoft
skillek voltak, tehát hogy
konfliktus megoldás,
analitikus gondolkodás,
mondjuk az nem egy szoft skill, de de
azonkívül még kritikus gondolkodás,
vezetői képességek,
menedzsmentképességek,
folyamatos tanulás. Tehát egy diák, aki
most kezdi el az egyetemet, attól még
végig kell menjen ezeken a folyamatokon,
és ezeket meg kell tanulja. Talán amit
érzek, az az, hogy egy programozónak
most már nem csak programozással kell
foglalkoznia, hanem lehet, hogy sok más
kvalitásra is szüksége van ahhoz, hogy
hatékonyan tudjon működni, mint
programozó. például fokozottan csapatban
dolgozni, fokozottan kommunikálni,
megtanulni kifejezni magát, megtanulni
leírni a gondolatait, esetleg meggyőzni
embereket. Tehát, hogy lehet, hogy a
csapatmunka fog felerősödni, és nem az a
az a kódolóképesség, ami ami eddig
izoláltan működött, hogy most leül a gép
elé és csak egyedül dolgozik, hanem
lehet, hogy kollaboratívan kell
dolgozzon majd. Mivel nagyobb lesz a
sebessége, ezért lehet, hogy többet kell
egyeztessen a klienssel vagy a többi
csapattársal. Te ezt hogy látod, Kares
ezt a a tehát eg egyrészt a a az én
megérzésemet, hogy lesz egy trend, ami
elmozdul a a hard skillekből, a soft
skillek fele, hogy egy programozónak
most már egyre többre van szüksége, és
lesz szüksége a jövőben. A másik pedig
pedig az, hogy
hogy igen, hogy ezek a személyek, akik
most elkezdik a az egyetemet, ezekben az
emberi dolgokban kell fejlődjenek, mint
a megértés. Például amúgy odaten a
felelősségvállalást is, odatenném a a
magát a az analitikus logikus
gondolkodást, az empátiát, tehát ugye
ezeket a a dolgokat.
>> Az általat felsorol skillek azok
vitathatatlanul nagyon-nagyon fontosak,
csak hogy én ezt nem tartom egy egy új
dolognak, tehát eddig is fontosak
voltak. Még akkor is, hogyha lehet,
hogyha a nem tudom, a klasszikus oktatás
vagy közoktatási rendszer, lehet, hogy
ez vitatható, hogy fektetett-e, vagy
fektet-e ezekre elég hangsúlyt, vagy
sem, lehet, ha nem, de attól még ezek
eddig is fontosak voltak. Ha konkrétan
programozásra gondolunk, akkor is már
régóta nagyon fontosak, tehát hogy már
régóta elérték azt a komplexitást a
szoftverek, amiket tipikusan
fejlesztünk, hogy ez ne egyéni munka
legyen. Tehát azt is szoktuk mindig
nagyon hangsúlyozni, hogy ez egy a
szoftverfejlesztésnek gyakorlatilag a
legeslefontosabb aspektusa, hogy hogy
csapatmunkáról szól. Hát van ugyanez a
sztereotípia ugye a programozókkal
szemben, hogy ezek valami furcsa lények,
akik sötét
sötét valami sötét pincékben görnyednek
valami billentyűzet fölött, és ott
mindenféle furcsa dolgokat ott művelnek
ezzel a bent, de ez ott bagányukba, de
ez nem így van, tehát hogy és már régóta
nem így van. Tehát azt hiszem kevés
olyan
szakma van, ami ami több
emberek közötti kommunikációt,
interakciót igényel, mint a mint a mint
a szoftverfejlesztés, mert hogy ez már
nagyon régóta csapatmunkáról szól. És
mint ilyen, az általad felsorolt szoft
skillek, azok azok rendkívül fontosak,
de nem most lettek fontosak, hanem
hanem eddig is fontosak voltak. Ezek
mellé fontos volt, és tovább úgy
gondolom, hogy továbbra is fontos lesz
egy szakmai tudás. Tehát ha visszatérek
arra a gondolatra, amit az előbb
mondtam, hogy a szakmai alapok azok
mesterséges intelligencia ide vagy oda,
azok továbbra is ugyanúgy, tehát ezt
kell megértsük, hogy ugyanúgy meg kell
legyenek. Sőt, ahogy mondtam, az, hogy
megvannak ezek a nagyon hatékony
eszközeink, ez nem azt jelenti, hogy
akkor most már elég lesz kevesebbet
tudni, hanem pont azt jelenti, hogy
többet kell tudni. Tehát továbbra is
ezek a ezek a szakmai alapok szerintem
szerintem ugyanúgy fontosak maradnak.
Ami még
talán, hogyha egy picit megint itt a itt
a szoftver fejlesztést vagy ezt a
technológiavilágot nézzük, ami ami
szerintem még fel fog értékelődni, vagy
már felértékelődött, az egyéb domaén
specifikus tudás. Tehát, hogy amellett,
hogy te tudod ezeket a fejlesztésre
szükséges, megvannak neked a
fejlesztéshez szükséges szakmai
alapjaid, vagy a háttered, amellett még
ezt tudjad kombinálni valamilyen más
doménium belüli tudással, ez szerintem
még
[Zene]
még még fel fog fel fog értékelődni.
Sumasumárum egy hát egy egyszerűbb példa
példára még visszatérve, hogy mondtad a
vagy említetted az előbb az email
generálásra használni mondjuk a nagy
nyelvi modellt. Oké, de azért, hogyha
egy fontos emailt kell elküldjél
valakinek, meg fogod nézni azt a amit ő
generált. Le fogod generáltatni lehet az
email, de megnézed és és
belejavíavítasz. És ez
ehhez neked tudnod kell, hogy hogyan
kell a megfelelő módon és formában
megfogalmazni egy egy ilyen emailt.
Tehát a tudásod meg kell legyen hozzá
meg kell legyen a tudásod ahhoz, tehát
hogyha ha tényleg hatékonyan akarod
használni ezeket az eszközöket, akkor
akkor meg kell legyen a tudásod ahhoz,
hogy hogy úgymond fel tudjad nekik tenni
a kérdést, vagy fel tudjad nekik adni a
feladatot, meg tudjad fogalmazni azt a
feladatot, és tudjad ellenőrizni,
értelmezni azt, amit ő
ő kiad.
kiad magából.
Már még egy egy gondolat, hogy hogy
ilyen hogy hogy hog visszatérve egy
picit, amit legelőször is mondtam, hogy
hogy eszközként tudjuk ezt egy nagyon
hatékony eszközként tudjuk ezt
használni, viszont eddig is voltak és
egyre hatékonyabb eszközeink. Egy példa
mondjuk oktatáshoz kötve, én én mindig
azt mondtam a a diákjaimnak, hogy ezek a
az ilyen olyan kódgenerátor túlok, ezek
eszközök, ezek ezek nagyon jók, tehát
nem ördögtől valóak, ezeket használjuk,
de csak azután, miután legalább már
egyszer megírtuk mi azt a kódot, és
tudjuk mi, hogy hogy kell megírni, és
értjük, utána használjuk ezeket az
eszközöket, amikor már tudni fogjuk azt,
hogy amit ő generál, az micsoda, tudjuk
értelmezni. tudjuk módosítani
>> és igen hozzá tudunk nyúlni, hogyha ha
szükséges.
>> Igen.
Én itt azt jegyezném meg, és szerintem
ez úgy nagyjából jól alá is támasztódott
ami nap folyamán, hogy ha valaki most
abban gondolkodik, hogy hol kell neki
tudást meg értéket hozzáadni, azt lehet
egy ilyen jelmondatnak elmondani, hogy
alacsony komplexitáson már nincs
hozzáadott érték a a az informatika
világában. Tehát ez sok szempontból
előjön. Az egyik például ez, amit
mondtál a soft skillekről, alacsony
komplexitás, ha valami olyan dolgot
akarok csinálni, amit egy ember meg tud
oldani. Például egy kezdő vállalkozás,
van egy startup ötlete, egy freelancer
programozót fog megkeresni, mert azok az
olcsóbbak.
Fejleszel le valamit, egy ember leül,
pizzás doboz, éjszaka, pince
lefejleszti. Mikor eljut oda, hogy ez
most már nagy, kell skálázni,
megbízhatóság kell, ha az ember elmegy
nyaralni két hétre, akkor nem állhat meg
az élet, hanem akkor már csapat kell. Ha
csapat kell, akkor már meg kell bízni
egy mondjuk egy szoftverházat, hogyha
ugye mi is outsourcingbaan
tevékenykedünk, tehát akkor már keresni
fog egy másik beszállítót, aki már
csapatot tud hozni, ahol három-négy
ember van ott, ők mind kell értsenek a
projekthez, satöbbi. A szoftverházaknak
az óradíjai nyilván magasabbak, mint az
egyedi fejlesztőhez. Nem azért van, mert
ki kell fizetni az irodát, meg ki kell
fizetni a könyvelőt, meg ilyesmi, hanem
azért van, mert ott már van szervezeti
tudás, már van olyasmi, hogy egy ember,
ha kimegy, van, aki át tudja venni a
helyét, ők együtt beszélgetnek,
brainstormingolnak, ettől hatékonyabbak
lesznek, gyorsabban dolgoznak, jobb
minőségű munkát végeznek. Tehát ezek a
soft skillek, amiket emlegettél, ezek is
mondta, ősi óta benne vannak, és ahogy
növekszik a komplexíásai terméknek,
egyre több kell belőlük. Nekem az egyik
kiváló példa, amit a egy pár hónappal
ezelőtt ütötte meg a a szememet, egy egy
youtuber mondta, akit akit szoktam
követni, egy technológiai youtuber, hogy
a Microsoft egy rakadt pénzt fektetett
mesterséges intelligenciába, és amúgy ők
is egy elég komoly leépítést csináltak,
nemrég, elküldtek egy rakad fejlesztőt,
és az indokok között ott szerepelt, hogy
sokkal hatékonyabbak lettek. És feltette
ez a a youtuber a kérdést, hogy ezt
látja, érti, és felmerül a kisördög a
válán, hogy ez valószínűleg azért van
ott a szövegben, nem azért, mert
valójában az AI nekik ezt megoldotta ezt
a hatékonyságnövelést,
hanem mert a befektetőiknek, a
részvénytulajdonosoknak el kell
magyarázni, hogy elégettünk végtelen sok
pénzt AI befektetésre, hogy akkor az
valahol látszódjon. Hát akkor ott
látszik, hogy spóroltunk a személyi
költségen, és akkor vallá sikerült
megtérteni a befektetést. De hogyha
mondjuk belegondolunk, hogy a Microsoft
Office-enek a forráskódját, a Wordöt meg
az Excelt, amiben én tudom, hogy elég
sokat dolgoztam ezekkel a a
technológiákkal,
20-30 éves olyan kódok vannak, hogy hogy
ember nem tudja már, hogy miért működik,
meg hogy működik, és ilyen mindenféle
legacy nagyon speciális apró kicsi
részletek, ezekről semmi nincs az
interneten. Tehát az Open nem fogja
tudni neked meg a chat GPT megmondani,
hogy a az office-ban az a 14 soród az
miért van ott, amiért ott van, de annak
ott kell lennie. És a nyakam teszem rá,
hogy az office fejlesztő közül, ha ki is
rúgtak embereket, a helyükre nem tudják
betenni az a mesterséges intelligenciát.
Tehát, hogy ott, ahol a komplexitás
nagyon megugrik, nagyon összefüggő,
végtelenül bonyolult rendszerek vannak,
és minden apró kicsi hangolásnak óriási
effektusa van, hatása a végeredményre,
oda nem nagyon lehet odaengedni egy
mesterséges intelligenciát. Tehát ez ez
nagyon-nagyon fontos, hogy amint a
komplexitás nő, ez az emberi
tulajdonság, hogy emlékszünk memória
intézeti vagy szervezeti memória,
szervezeti tudás, ezek ezek mind kelleni
fognak.
>> És gondolod, hogy itt az E nem fog tudni
segíteni, hogy ezt a szervezeti
információt megtartsa és így kontextusba
tartsa? Nagyon sokan dolgoznak ezzel,
sőt még még olyasmiket is hallottam,
vagy így látok a világban, hogy ha
például engem alkalmaznak egy céghez,
akkor megyek, viszem a kisomat, és amin
ott dolgozok, és amit ott megtanulok, az
kérdés, hogy az beleépül az énomba, és
azt viszem a következő céghez, vagy az a
a céges I-ba kell beépüljen, és ott
tanul, és erről az emberek beszélgetnek.
Én nem tudom, hogy hova fogunk eljutni.
Az emberi agy az elég speciális. Nekünk
vannak olyan projektjeink, amin
gyakorlatilag amióta az egyetemet
elvégeztem, tehát 2000, mit tudom én, 7
óta, am még el se végeztem az egyetemet,
azóta dolgozok rajta. Nem dolgozok sokat
már rajta, mert millió más dolom van, de
van olyan, hogy bejön egy kérdés, hogy
srácok, itt van ez a két sor valami,
magyarázzátok el, hogy ez mi a francér
van. És nem tudom, hogy ez kóros tünet
vagy nem, de hogy én emlékszek, elmondom
nekik, hogy emberek 2009-ben
emlékezzetek vissza, volt egy, nem
tudom, izraeli ügyfél, akinek az volt a
baja, hogy és azt
>> ez kórus.
>> Oké. Tehát, hogy hogy van egy ilyen
memória, és ezzel az a helyzet, hogy
hogy ha nem tudod teljesen lefedni a a
az eseteidet ilyen úgynevezett
automatikus tesztekkel, tehát ha
mindenesetre szépen meg volna csinálva,
hogy az izraeli ügyfélnek a problémája
be van építve, és ha valamit elrontunk
neki, akkor azt automatikus rendszerek
megfogják és kijavítsák, és ezt lehet
végigerálni,
akkor neked nincs esélyed arra, hogy egy
változtatásra azt tud mondani, hogy ezt
mi nagy megbízhatósággal beengedhetjük a
kódbázisunkba.
Arról nem is beszélve, hogy ez a domén
tudás, amit Káro is mondott, ez
nagyon-nagyon fontos. Tehát azok a
projektek, amin én tizenvalahány éve
dolgozok, tehát én nem vagyok nyelvi
szakértő, viszont tizenvány év dolgozok
egy olyan szoftver projekten, ami a a
nyelvi iparágnak dolgozik, és olyan
dolgokat tudok, amiket csak azok tudnak,
akik ott ott reggeltől estig ezt eszik
és isszák, mert ebből élnek. És ha
valaki tőlem megkérdezi, akkor néha volt
már olyan kávézásnál olyan ilyen
szakszavakat meg folyamatokat tudtam
elmesélni, az emberek kézték, hogy mi a
francért tudsz te ilyeneket, mint
informatikus. Hát mondom, azért, mert
ezt a doméniumot szolgálom ki. Tehát az
a
ács vagy asztalos, amely koporsókat
csinál, biztos, hogy nagyon sokat tud
arról, hogy mondjuk egy morbid lesz a
példa, de hogy egy halottnak milyen
fizikai tulajdonságai vannak, nem tudom
mennyi folyadékot ereszt, meg mennyire
merev meg ilyesmi, mert neki ezt tudni
kell ahhoz, hogy jó koporsú tudjon
csinálni. Az informatika is ilyen. Mi
egy kiszolgáló iparág vagyunk. Az
informatikát senki nem veszi azért, hogy
legyen egy applikációja, amit nem tudom,
feltesz a polcra, azt azért vesszük,
hogy nem tudom tudjon bevásárlistát
kezelni, meg nyissa ki a garázsajtót,
meg egyebeket csináljon. És az, aki a
garázsajtó kinyitó applikációt csinálja,
annak nagyon kell tudni, hogy olyan
applikációt ne csináljunk, ami csukja le
a garázsajót, de hogy mondjuk a
gyereknek a feje ott van a garázsajtó
alatt, akkor nem állítjuk meg az ajtót,
hanem tovább nyomjuk, mert le kell tenni
a földig. Tehát, hogy a domén tudás
nagyon kelleni fog, és innováció mindig
abban van, amikor te valami újat
csinálsz. Tehát ha a garázsajtókat már
van 16000 garázsajtó csukó szoftver,
akkor persze az AI fog generálni egy
17-et olcsón, csak az senkinek nem fog
kelleni. Tehát itt itt mind megint az
van, hogy az új innovatív dolgoknak a
legenerálása az a hozzáadott információ
kelleni fog, és az az csak az embertől
fog jönni.
>> Teljesen megnyugodtan. Köszönöm szépen,
hogy ilyen optimistan álltok ehhez a
témához. Tényleg bizonyos szempontból
rengeteg új dolgot mondtatok nekem, amin
érdemes gondolkozzak. Arra gondoltam,
hogy utolsó témaként feldobnám magát azt
a a a
digitális székelyföldet, amit
hihetetlen, hogy milyen jól
összeraktatok. Megnéztem a programot, de
egy kicsit nem bánnám, hogyha átnéznénk
ezt a programot, és elmondanátok, hogy
ezzel a jubileumi 10. évben
itt Székely udvarhelyen mivel is fog
készülni a digitális székelyföld
számunkra?
>> Ühüm. Hát ha nem bánjátok, akkor én egy
picit talán kontextusba helyezném, vagy
elmondanám, hogy mi is ez a digitális
székelyföld konferencia, és akkor utána
szerintem a programról részleteiben
inkább Sándor fog beszélni, mint az idei
konferenciának a programfelelőse,
illetve szakmai koordinátora. Szóval ez
a digitális székelyföld, ez az IT plus
clusternek a az egyik szakmai
rendezvénye. Tulajdonképpen mondhatjuk,
hogy a legnagyobb
szakmai rendezvénye a klusternek. Az IT
plus cluster, ez pedig az erdélyi, főleg
székelyföldi IT cégeket tömörítő
szakmai szervezet, aki mint ilyen
együttműködésben
fejti ki a tevékenységeit helyi oktatási
intézményekkel, önkormányzatokkal, és
olyan projekteket
visz, amelyek amelyek valamilyen módon a
helyi IT szektornak a fejlődését
előmozdítják, facilitálják. Talán ami
kívülről leginkább látszik ezek közül,
azok a különböző ilyen oktatási, képzési
programok, illetve a szakmai
rendezvények
szakmai rendez és ebbe a szakmai
rendezvények kategóriába tartozik ugye
ez a digitális székelyföld konferencia
is a klaszternek egyébként más
rendezvényei mellett, amilyen a
digitális skalák, a klaszternek a
hekatonja, vagy a hargita informatikus
találkozó és így tovább. A digitális
székelyföld konferencia talán a
legnagyobb ezek közül, tehát ami a
legnagyobb
létszámú közönséget is megmozdítja.
Gyakorlatilag most már az évek során
mondhatjuk azt, hogy Erdély legnagyobb
magyar nyelvű szakmai fórumává
nőtte ki magát a területen. Története az
ami 2013-ban indult. Alapvetően egy
vándor konferenciaként
volt kitalálva. Hát meg volt szervezve.
Hát az első az Árkoson volt, ugye egy
jóval kisebb rendezvényről beszélünk.
Ott egyetlen nem párhuzamos szekciók,
hanem egyetlen egy szekcióban zajlottak
az előadások. Assiszem egy-két
támogatóval, hat-hét előadóval, 40-50
résztvevővel. Na, ez azóta azért
lényegesen megváltozott, megnövekedett.
Évről évre tudott fejlődni. Milyen
szempontból a rendezvény volt utána
Tusnádon, Bálványoson, Szovátán,
Sepiszen Györgyön, Marosásárejen,
Csikszeredában. És az egyetlen helyszín
egyébként, ahol most már többször
visszatér a a Székely udvarhely. Ugye
itt volt, ez lesz a harmadik kiadás.
udvarhelyen volt még 2018-ban, illetve
2023-ban
megszervezve a rendezvény. És hát
ha szerkezetét nézzük, vagy a
koncepcióját nézzük, akkor gyakorlatilag
egy klasszikus
konferencia olyan szempontból, hogy úgy
áll össze a programja, amiről majd
mindjárt
Sándor mesélni fog többet, hogy délelőtt
plenáris előadások zajlanak, és délután
pedig
három-négy párhuzamos szekcióban
zajlanak előadások, beszélgetések,
workshopok. Ez egy ö két két teljes
napot felülelő ö szakmai rendezvény. Ö
nagyon fontos, mint ahogy általában ezek
a
az én olvasatomban ezek a ezek a szakmai
rendezvények több szempontból is is
nagyon fontosak a a klasszter, illetve a
helyi szakmai közösség életében. Tehát
egyrészt
segítenek abban, hogy láthatóbbá tegyük
a szektort kifele is a helyi szektort.
nagyon jó
találkozási pontok, illetve a kapcsolat
hálópítésének a szempontjából nagyon
nagy a jelentőségük. egy tudást is meg
tud valósulni ezeknek a kereteiben,
illetve nagyon sok, ami aminek nagyon
őrülendek, hogy ezeken a rendezvényeken
nagyon sok konkrét együttműködés
született, és nagyon sok konkrét
kezdeményezés
indult el az előző éveknek ez a
tapasztalata, és én nagyon remélem, hogy
a az ideinek sem lesz más.
Azt gondolom, hogy egy nagyon erős
szakmai programot sikerült
összerakni az idénre, úgyhogy úgyhogy
vagány és izgalmas lesz a rendezvény
egyébként nem csak IT-soknak, elsősorban
ugye ez egy IT szakmai konferencia, de
lesznek, tehát vannak olyan részei,
mindjárt ki is fog derülni abból, amit
Sándor elmond, vannak olyan részei, amik
nem IT-ban dolgozóknak is számára is
érdekesek, izgalmasak lehetnek szerintem
jó programnak ígérkezik az idei.
Gratulálok is ezért a programfelelős
szakmai koordinátornak, és akkor meg őt
fogom megkérni, hogy akkor egy kicsit
meséljen.
>> Köszi. Igen.
Életemen nem szerveztem még
konferenciát, úgyhogy izgalmas volt így
belülről látni. Nem biztos, nem vagyok
benne biztos, hogy a következő vágyam
az, hogy egy újabbat szervezek, de ettől
függetlenül a a feladatot most már,
hogyha el kellett végezni, akkor
elvégeztük. Ahogy Karz is mondta, a
konferenciának alapvetően történelemből
is látjuk, hogy kétféle közönsége van.
Egyfelől vannak informatikusok, akik
vagy informatikus munkavállalók, vagy
informatikus cégvezetők hasonlók,
illetve vannak olyan emberek, akik nem
informatikusok, de olyan iparákban
dolgoznak, ahol az informatikára erősen
építenek, ami valljuk be manapság
majdnem minden iparág, de hogy mi
dedikáltan meg akarjuk célozni azokat az
embereket is, és nekik is akarunk
tartalmat adni, akik akik építeni
akarnak a a digitalizációra.
Az IT cluster lévén, hogy informatikus
cégeket tömörít. Nyilván itt mi látjuk,
van kapcsolati hálónk, hogy milyen
digitalizációs trendek vannak. Egyfelőtt
tudjuk, hogy milyen tudások érdekesek. a
be a klastercégeknek is vannak különböző
profiljai, és akkor ott neki van olyan
tudása, ami a többieknek esetleg
nincsen. Tehát ezt szeretnénk kicsit
megmutatni, illetve meg szeretnénk
mutatni a különböző
szektorképviselőknek, hogy mi akiknek
bedolgozunk, akár külföldre, akár
máshova, az adott iparágakban milyen
dolgokat használnak, és akkor ebből
esetleg valami átcsaroghat ide is. És
ahogy Karus mondtam, egy csomó
együttműködés kialakult ebből az én
esetemben is, csak hogy egy példát
mondjak.
két évvel ezelőtti konferencián itt volt
a Budapesti Műszaki Egyetemnek az egyik
ilyen IT biztonsággal kapcsolatos
laboratóriuman, amiv eladásokat
tartottak és ennek eredmények épp a Bábs
Egyetemre is tudtunk hozni egy olyan
tantárgyat, ami az IT biztonsággal
foglalkozik, és gyakorlatilag az anyagot
és a csó mindent ők adtak hozzá, a
segítségük nélkül az esélytelen lett
volna, hogy egy ilyen tantárgyat be
tudjunk vezetni ilyen gyorsan, és
amilyen támogatást adtak, az az
felbecsülhetetlen volt. Jó, és akkor
szerintem végig is mennék a programon,
egy pár szót mondanék minden minden
programpontról, úgyhogy elnézést, hogy a
telefonomat nézem közben. Pénteken
indulunk, van egy plenári szekció. Az
első előadónk az Palkovics László lesz,
aki a Magyarország mesterséges
intelligenciáért felő kormánybiztosa.
Ahogy ezt is mondtam, ez egy szakmai
rendezvény. Bár Palkovics úr nyilván
politikus is, de nagyon komoly szakmai
háttere is van, úgyhogy ő itt a magyar
emi stratégiáról fog beszélni, és majd
később lesz neki szerep adva máshol is.
A következő eladásunkat az Horvai
Gergely fogja tartani. Ő egy mesterséges
intelligenciás ilyen adattudós, már
nagyon régóta ilyen adattudománnyal
foglalkozik. Az utóbbi időben a az, amit
be fog mutatni, az OECD-nek
fejlesztettek egy olyan
chatbotot, ilyen mesterséges
intelligencia apú technológiát, aminek
az volt a sarokköve, az volt a fő
elvárás, hogy ez megbízható kell legyen.
Itt a beszélgetésben is előkerült, hogy
néha nem megbízhatóak azért a
mesterséges intelligenciák úgynevezett
hallucinációt csinálnak. Na ez ami az új
CD-nél nem fér bele. Tehát hogyha valaki
az USD-vel beszélget, akkor nem azt
gondolja, hogy Romániának a GDP-jét majd
kamúzni kell. Úgyhogy bár néha szoktuk,
hanem hogy itt valami megbízható kell.
és erről fog beszélni ezt, hogyan lehet
összerakni. A következő eladónk az Bokor
József lesz. Ő a budapesti műszaki
Egyetemnek volt tanszékvezetője és az
egyik legki kiemelkedőbb professzor
Magyarországon informatika területekén
akadémikus is. Ő arról fog beszélni,
hogy a Magyarországon az autóipar és az
autógyártás az egy elég
hangsúlyos terület. És Magyarországon a
a az adatgyűjtést, az adatmegosztást és
az erre épülő mesterséges intelligenciás
projekteket az autóiparban hogyan
koordinálták és ott
milyen tevékenység zajlottak. A
következő előadó az Horvát Márkó lesz. Ő
is Magyarországról jön, a Hungrestakinak
az alkalmazottja. Ő logisztikáról fog
beszélni, logisztikai megoldásoknak a az
algoritmus megoldásáról. Ebben nem lesz
mesterség és intelligencia speciciál.
különböző nagy cégeknek, mint például
Huawei és és más cégeknek vannak olyan
ilyen kihívásai, ahol kitesznek olyan
problémákat, amik nekik probléma, és nem
tudják a belső csapataikkal olyan
szinten megoldani, amilyenre szeretnék,
vagy lehet, hogy megtudják, de nem
akarják elmondani, és ezekre a
versenyekre lehet jelentkezni.
Márkoiknak, a Markoiknak a a csapata
nagyon kiemelkedő eredményeket értek el
a Huawei bizonyos logisztikai
problémáin, és valószínűleg erről meg
ugye egyáltalán az ilyen
versenykoszisztémákról fog majd előadást
tartani. Következő eladunk az Bihari
Birja lesz. Ő egy klastercégnek a
vezetője és a címét az előadásának még
nem árulhatjuk el. Egy viszonylag nagy
horderejű bejelentésre készül, úgyhogy
ez legyen meglepetés a a konferencián.
Utána Kovács Sándor fog beszélni. Ő a
Pécsi Ovostudományi Egyetemnek a az
adatmenedzsere. Az ő feladata az az,
hogy a a pécsi klinikának és a környékén
a az egészségügyben amilyen adatok
előállnak, azt azt kezeljék, tárolják.
Ez nyilván törvényi kötelezettségük is,
de amiről ő beszélni fog, az az, hogy
hogyan oldották meg, hogy ezeket az
adatokat
úgy kezeljék és tárolják, hogy tudják a
az egészségügy javítására felhasználni
saját belső felhasználatra, illetve
monetizálni is. Tehát hogyha mondjuk egy
orvosi kutatáshoz valakinek egyszer csak
kelleni fog, hogy öt évvel ezelőtt az
adott vérnyomású, zöld szemű és Adidas
tip használó betegeknek milyen
statisztikái voltak, akkor ezeket ők
tudják produkálni, és ebből pénzt
tudjanak generálni. Itt én nem titkolt
célom, hogy szeretném, hogyha a
székelyföldi magán és állami
intézmények, egészségügyi intézmények a
vezetői eljönnének erre az előadásra,
nagyon szívesen össze is hozzuk őket,
hogy hátha ide is lehetne ilyen típusú
munkafolyamatokat behozni, és be
tudnának csatlakozni abba az
ökoszisztémába, amit Sándorik építettek
Pécsen. És a a plenári szekciót itt
Hajdú Gábor fogja zárni. Ő a
Székelyföldi Iá stratégiának a
bemutatásáról fog majd egy pár percben
szónokolni. Utána van egy finom ebéd, és
akkor az ebéd után szekcióprogramok
fognak jönni majd, ami azt jelenti, hogy
párhuzamosan mennek. A párhuzamos
programoknak kétféle kategóriája van.
Vannak workshopok, amik egy ilyen
nagyobb lélegzetvételű másfél két-három
órás
események, ahova végig koncentrálni
kell, ott kell lenni. Ilyenből minden
napra kettő van. A az első nap egy
elosztott rendszerfejlesztés a dot
Microsoftnak a DNET spire technológiáját
fogom én bemutatni az első slotban ebéd
előtt. És ebéd után pedig Balázs áron
napró lánctól fog tartani egy hétköznapi
produktivitást cégvezetőknek mesterség
és intelligenciaeszközökkel workshopot.
Ez dedikáltan egy olyan workshop, ami
nem informatikusoknak szól, és pont azt
akarja bemutatni, hogy ha én nem tudom,
van egy kis pékségem, vagy van egy egy,
nem tudom, kis manufaktúrám
szappantyártok, vagy bármi ilyesmi, hogy
tudok én valami olyasmit csinálni, ami
több mint a chat GPT, és már hasznos,
olcsón, hatékonyan be tudom építeni az
üzleti folyamataimba. Tehát ez lesz a
két workshop a párhuzamos szekciókból.
A program még alakulhat. Ezt van még
egy-két kérdőjel, hogy valami mozoghat,
de a jelen állapot szerint a ezen a
napon lesz egy mesterséges intelligencia
szekció. A generatív AI utáni világról
fogunk beszélni. Itt
Andr Tim arról fog beszélni, ő már
nagyon régóta ilyen gépi, nyelvi
feldolgozással foglalkozó kutató, és
nemrég tért haza Székelyföldre. Arról
fog beszélni, hogy az AI adopció
vállalatokban működik, milyen
tapasztalatai voltak, valójában, hogy is
néz ki ez a világ. És az előadásának
címe az, hogy AI adopció a valóság a
Hype után, úgyhogy nagyon szépen rimel
arra is, amiről mi ma beszélgettünk.
Utána KTI Beatrix fogsz beszélni a
Crisis labdól. Ez egy IT biztonsági
kutató laboratórium Budapesten a a
mesterséges intelligenciáknak a
támadhatóságairól és a biztonsági
problémáiról.
Székely Barnabás fog beszélni arról,
hogy az európai AInnek milyen kitételei
vannak, illetve az AI hogyan próbálja a
mesterséges intelligencia kutatásokat és
felhasználást valamilyen szinten
szabályozni, és ezt jogi környezettel
alátámasztani.
És a legvégén pedig Szabó Péter fog
beszélni arról, hogy
hogyan lehet ügynökalapú mesterséges
intelligenciákat fejleszteni vállalati
innovációban, hogyan lehet ezeket
2026-ban betenni. Ö gyakorlatilag az
idei évnek ez a az agentic volt a a az
úgynevezett buzwe. És utolsó előadó
ebben a szekcióban Csató Lehel lesz a
Bábes Bói egyetem
magyar matematika informatika
intézetének a professzora. Ő a
magyarázható AI-ról fog majd beszélni.
Tehát amikor az AI egy kérdésre ad
valamilyen választ, az nem elég, hogy
kiköptük a választ, meg is kell tudni
indokolni és el kell tudni magyarázni,
hogy miért lett az a válasz. Nekik ez
aik kutatási területük az utóbbi időben.
Jó, lesz egy orvosi technológiás
panelbeszélgetés, ahol különböző előadók
fognak majd arról beszélgetni, hogy az
orvosi
világban a mesterség és intelligencia
milyen támogatásokat tud adni. Itt
diagnosztikáról és egyéb
[Zene]
egyéb területekről lesz szó. Többek
között lesz az orvosi álhírek
kiszűrésével kapcsolatos emi
kutatásokról is előadás.
Utána lesz egy kétrészes beszélgetés.
Ezek panelbeszélgetések lesznek. A címe
ennek a szekciónak az lesz, hogy
kutatásfejlesztés és felsőoktatás
regionális szerepkörök a világban. Pont
az, amiről beszélgettünk itt Európa,
Kína és társai.
Ez két részre fog oszlani. Az első
részben Saraf Hassan, a a budapesti
műszakegyetemnek a rektora fog
beszélgetni Horv Kis Gergellyel. Kis
Gergely a az Arm Hungarynek az ügyvezető
igazgatója, tehát ő az Nvidiával hasonló
kaliberben játszó cég ügyvezetője.
Arról fognak beszélgetni, hogy
innovációt az oktatásba hogyan lehet
betenni, hogyan lehet azt finanszírozni,
hogyan egy ilyen nagy globális cég, mint
mondjuk az ARM, hogyan szerez tudást,
hogyan építi be a lokális kisegyetemeket
az ő életciklusába, és hasonló dolgokról
fogunk beszélgetni. Szerintem ez egy
nagyon érdekes beszélgetés lesz. És
utána pedig egy panelbeségetés lesz a a
helyben releváns vagy a helyi
hallgatóságnak diáknak releváns
felsőtatási intézmények rektori
szintjén.
Itt képviselve lesz a a bábesi
tudományegyetem, a szapiencia
Magyarországról az Óbudai Egyetem meg a
meg a budapesti műszaki
egyetem, illetve Palkovics László itt is
meg fog jelenni. Ő ugyan nem egyetemi
vezető, viszont nagyon sok magyarországi
kis és közepes méretű egyetemnek a a
felsálázásában, konszolidációjában vett
részt. Vannak nagyon jó és nagyon rossz
tapasztalatai, és ezekről fogja majd
megosztani velünk a véleményét. Illetve
egy nyilván szóba fog kerülni az, amiről
itt is beszéltünk, hogy a mesterséges
intelligencia hogyan kell hasson,
visszahasson a az oktatásra. Lesz egy
szekciónk digitális eszköz
digitális előkészítés, gyártás és
folyamat folyamatkövetésről. Ez
tipikusan azoknak szól, akik valamilyen
gyártási folyamatban használnak
digitalizációt. És akkor erről fogunk
beszélgetni. Itt Bek Zoltán a Mortoftól
fogok beszélni, illetve helyi
vállalkozók elég erősen jelen vannak.
Bíró Zsombor az Engmatektől, ő egy csíki
fémmegmunkáló cégnek a vezetője. Litasi
Levente az Al Technologiesól, ugye
Farkaslaki légzsákárból, illetve
Kiskálmának is Elektroparktól fog majd
jönni. Ök mind olyan fizikai
gyártófolyamatokban segédkeznek, meg oda
dolgoznak be, amiben nagyon erős a
digitalizációs jelenlét, de ők a fizikai
valósággal dolgoznak, tehát nem ilyen
telefonapplikációk meg egyebek, hanem
komoly dolgokkal dolgoznak.
illetve aznap lesz egy agrárd
digitalizációs szekció is, székelyföldön
is, de úgy általában is az agráriumnak a
digitalizáció az egy nagyon fontos
dolog, és erről fognak majd tudni
beszélni itt az előadóink, csak hogy egy
pár
intézményt nevezzek meg, ahonnan jönnek.
Magyarországon a magyarázsi
éltmányegyetemnek a precíziós
gazdálkodás tanszékéről, illetve a a
magyar precízi gazdálkodási egy
egyesülettől, illetve Székelyföldből, a
Székelyföld az okos farmtól is jönnek
majd előadók. Jó, ezzel zárul a pénteki
napunk, és akkor nézzük a szombatot.
>> Elképesztő, ez még csak az első nap.
>> Ez még csak az első nap. Így van.
Céges kollégáknak bedobtuk a programot,
ugye nyilván támogatásért cserébe ők
majd mehetnek a a rendezvényre, és az
egyetlen panaszuk az volt, hogy túl sok
a párhuzamos jó helye van, menni kell.
Mondtam srácok, ez van. Viszont van egy
olyan jó hír, hogy valószínűleg lesznek
felvételek róluk, tehát majd később
esetleg ezeket meg tudjuk osztani. A
25-e szombati napnak a két fővonala van.
Az az egyik az a a az IT iparnak az
emberi oldala, a másik pedig ilyen IT
biztonság és termékfejlesztés
irány. Az első eladónk az Penkő Ilona
lesz. Ő a egy kolozsvári cégnek a a
learning and development vezetője. Azért
felel, hogy a szervezeten belől az
emberek folyamatosan tanuljanak és
képezzék magukat. Arról fog beszélni,
hogy ezt hogyan kell megcsinálni, milyen
nemzetközi trendek vannak és mire
érdemes itt figyelni. A következő
eladás, én ezt várom a legjobban,
bevallom őszintén, Kis Dániel az ARM
Hungarytől egy szoftver architektúra
igazgató, és arról fog beszélni, hogy a
mobiltelefonokba, kifejezetten az
Android operációs rendszerrel üzemelő
telefonokban, amilyen ARM processzorokat
tettek, ott az IT biztonsági
megoldásokat ők hard szinten milyen
megoldásokkal támogatták. És akkor itt
belenekhetünk abba, hogy amikor a
processzorokat tervezték és
kialakították, akkor akkor milyen
gondolatokon mentek végig. Szerintem
ilyen szintű szakmai tartalom nagyon
ritkán keverhetik Székelyföldre, úgyhogy
mindenképp javaslom mindenkinek itt,
hogy hogy jöjjön el.
Utána lesz egy digitális
termékfejlesztésről szóló előadás, amit
Süket Csaba fog tartani. Süket Csaba
onnan lehet ismerős a szakmai körökben,
hogy a BF Romániát gyakorlatilag a
nullából ő építette fel, és azon kívül ő
egy másik több mint 400 hősre
feltudzasztott szoftver céget épített az
eniteket, amit aztán ő eladott, és most
különböző startup projektjei vannak. Ő
arról fog beszélni, hogy minden, ami a
digitális termékfejlesztésben, nem a
programozás, tehát az ötletelés, a
piackutatás, a finanszírozás
megszerzése, az értékesítés, a support,
és ezt lehetne nagyon hosszan sorolni.
Milyen tevékenységek vannak itt? Milyen
buktatók vannak? Nagyjából mik a
receptek és neki milyen tapasztalatai
voltak erről. Ezzel fog beszél, erről
fog beszélni.
Van még két olyan slotunk, ami nincs
elmondva, hogy ki lesz ott. Az egyikre
már
igazából ezt ki is hagynám, mert még nem
akarom lelőni a poénokat. olyan
szempontból, hogy ameddig az előadók nem
igazolták vissza, hogy hogyan fognak
előadni, akkor ezt nem tölteném meg.
Viszont egy, ami már fix, Gfi Csaba
nemzetközi szoftverértékesítő, ő
székelyudvarhely amúgy fog mesélni
arról, hogy hogy nemzetközi szinten
szoftverező szervice szolgáltatásokat
hogyan lehet marketingelni, hogyan lehet
eladni és az ő legfont, tehát a az
üzenetén, az előadásának a témája arról
fog szólni, hogy azok a szoftverek, amik
AI-t tartalmaznak, na azoknak a
marketinge hogyan működik és mit csinál.
Konkrétan ők már tudják, hogy valamire
rátenni azt, hogy AI alapú az az
kontraproduktív, mert sok esetben ez
pont, hogy csökkenti az eladásokat, és
arról fog beszélni, hogy hogy ezt az AI
beépítettséget hogyan kell, hogyan
érdemes mutatni a a hallgatók fel.
Ez nap ezen a napon is lesznek
workshopok. A biztonság kedvére most már
nem kettő, hanem három van, tehát van
olyan, amikor workshopból is
párhuzamosak vagyunk. lesz egy
workshopunk, webalkalmazás egy óra alatt
a közösség bevonásából élőben. Ezt Szabó
Péter fogja tartani. Gyakorlatilag egy
nagyon hasonló demót fog csinálni, mint
amit a a az Open AI deven is. Ott
helyben élőben valamilyen alkalmazást a
közönség igényei alapján össze fognak
rakni egy utolsó eseményen, ahol ezt a
workshopot vagy ennek egy előző
verzióját megcsinálta, ott ilyen juhász
kutyákat követő alkalmazást raktunk
össze kettő perc alatt a a hát nem kettő
perc, egy óra alatt a a közönséggel.
Ilona, Ben Ilon, aki tartotta az éges
belső fejlesztésekről szóló előadását,
fog tartani egy workshopot tudatos
karrierépítés alapjai, az egyéni
fejlesztési terv. Ezt tipikusan olyan
embereknek ajánljuk, akik fejlesztők és
a szervezeten belül szeretnék a saját
előrelépésüket kicsit facilitálni, vagy
tudatosabban tervezni a saját
karrierjüket,
illetve lesz egy hosszabb workshop.
Aiszlap fogja tartani két oktatóval
hiba, hibá kihasználása a bináris
programokban. Ez gyakorlatilag szoftver
hackerés és a a rossz szoftvereknek a a
detekciója, észrevételek kihasználása
témakörben lesz majd. Jó, és akkor itt
is vannak szekcióink. Lesz egy
jövőkutatás, utópiák és disztópiák
szekció. Itt itt alapvetően
szociológusok, informatikusok fognak
arról beszélni, hogy ez a digitalizáció
milyen társadalom fele vezet minket,
hogyan fog ez hatni a fiatalokra, a
nagyon idősekre, a gyártásra, a
termelésre, a szolgáltatásra, a
fogyasztásunkra. Tehát ez egy a nevéből
is látszik, hogy jövő kutatás ez egy
ilyen ez egy létező tudomány és
alapvetően olyan kérdésekkel
foglalkozik, hogy 5 10 20 30 éves
távlaton vajon hol leszünk és ezekről a
dolgokról szeretnének beszélni itt a az
előadóink. Lesz egy e-kereskedelem
szekciónk
itt. Ennek az a lényege, hogy olyan
szervezeteket próbáltunk összehozni,
akik online értékesítenek. Nyilván ez a
digitalizációra erősen
épülő szektor, viszont nem a
technológiai megvalósításról, hanem a
hanem a az üzleti oldaláról fogjuk ezt
megfogni ezt a beszélgetést. Itt Molnár
Judit fog részt venni a helyén
valóbóltól. Ugye nekik az a
specialitásuk egy alapvetően kis
szervezet és elég speciális és az is,
amit értékesítenek helyi termékeket
mindenhova online értékesíteni. A nem
tudom a kénosi kolbászt bukaresbe
eladni, az egy annak annak az online
kihívásai azok nagyon mások, mint amit
az Nvidia küzd.
Pálszilárd a Melinda Instáttól fog
jönni. Náluk is nagyon sok speciális
dolog van. Talán egy, amit kiemelnék,
hogy ők egy ugye a Melindá egy olyan
szervezet, ami értékesít is, de a saját
versenytársainak is értékesít, hiszen
nagy tételben is árulnak, meg
kistételben is. És ennek végtelen sok
komplexitása van, hogy hogyan lehet azt
megoldani, hogy a saját versenytársamnak
is adok el dolgokat, de hogy azért mégis
azt is el kéne adni. Nagyon érdekes
beszélgetésnek nézünk elébe. Buzogány
Attila a kidlettől fog jönni. Szerintem
ez egy külön kiemelendő sikertörténet.
Egy keresztúri vállalkozásról beszélünk,
aki a online kereskedelemben ilyen
outlet típusú
dolgokat árulnak online, és
gyakorlatilag a Teumuval meg a Shinnel
versenyeznek. Egy nagyon-nagyon szép
történet, és itt vannak a a kert
végében, úgyhogy örülünk, hogy ők is
részt vesznek a konferencián. Ide is még
lesznek majd más beszélgető partnerek,
akiket még nem tudok megerősíteni. Lesz
egy digitális termékfejlesztés
szekciónk, ahol olyan történeteket
osztunk meg, ahol pont nem csak a
programozásra tesszük a hangsúlyt, hanem
hogy egy egész termék életcikluson végig
ívelve hogyan lehetett végigmenni a a
fejlesztésen. És itt mire kell figyelni.
Itt Lukács László alpár fog beszélni a
cognitív creators arról, hogy ha egy
digitális terméket fel kell értékelni,
mert mondjuk egy befektető jön és meg
akarja nézni, hogy mennyit is ér neki ez
a termék, hogy egy ilyen du diligence
processben milyen problémák lehetnek és
és itt mire kell figyelni. Ezek után
Szilágyi István fog beszélni. Az
udvarhelyek talán ismerhetik a nevét.
A városgazdálkodási osztályon is volt,
meg ugye alapvetően Udvarhendi jól
ismert könyvelési szakértő. Ő az ebillió
szoftverről fog beszélni, ami egy egy
online számlázási felület. Gyakorlatilag
arról van szó, hogy Istánik nagyon jól
ráéreztek, hogy amikor a román
szabályozásban bevezették, hogy a a
cégeknek kötelező lesz online számlázást
csinálni, akkor egy helyi
szoftverfejlesztő cég és István, mint
kiváló könyvelési meg pénzügyi szakember
összetárultak. És mivel István tudta,
hogy mi kell ahhoz, hogy egy online
számlázó rendszer jó legyen, meg tudta
mondani, hogy mit kell fejleszteni. A
fejlesztők lefejlesztették. És szerintem
ez egy udvarhelyi sikertörténet, hogy
helyi vá kisvállalkozók egy teljesen hát
nem azt mondom, hogy globális, mert ugye
a román jogrendszerre épített, de egy
román országos piacon egy egy szemmel
látható sikeres projektet tudtak
összegrundolni, és ez a nullától az
eladásig végigvitték. Tehát ez egy
nagyon szép történet.
Jakabos Tünde fog beszélni arról, hogy
hogy az ügyféltámogatás az mennyire
fontos a a szoftverfejlesztési
életciklusban. Tehát nagyon
leegyszerűsítve az az ökölszabály az az,
hogy új ügyfeleket nagyon drágán lehet
szerezni, és ki tudja, hogy mennyi pénzt
hoznak. De ha van egy meglévő ügyfelünk,
aki elégedett és visszajön, rá sokkal
jobban lehet építeni. És ennek a
mindenféle csinyáváról fog nekünk majd
beszélni.
Süket Csaba a plenáris előadását kicsit
konkrétabban egy-két fókusz területre
fogja majd
ráirányítani, és ugyancsak erről a
digitális te megfejlesztés valós
akadályiról fog beszélni. Különféle
stratégiákat fog megosztani, amiket ők
használtak. Emellett lesz egy hardcore
tech szekciónk. A hardcore tech az
kifejezetten szoftverfejlesztőknek van
számva.
Itt az előadóink Makaranci Zoltán lesz.
Ő egy
nagyon kiemelkedő webes
frontendfejlesztő, és alapvetően arról
fog beszélni nekünk, hogy a a szoftver
szállítási folyamatok, tehát a a
fejlesztéstől a tesztelésen a
kitelepítésig vett automatikus
folyamatok, tipikusan webes frontend
esetben, hogyan kell azt jól csinálni,
milyen hibák vannak, hogyan lehet azt
nagyon rosszul csinálni, és erről fogja
megosztani a tapasztalatait.
Szabó Mihály, ő egy jelenleg
Franciaországban élő, szintén az
OECD-vel együtt dolgozó, független ilyen
AI Fak fejlesztő. Ő arról fog beszélni,
hogy ezek a mesterséges intelligencia
alapú munkafolyamatok és rendszereknek
az üzemeltetése, a az üzembehelyezése
hogyan működik. Emelops és hasonló
kulcszavak mentén lehet az ő előadását
karakterizálni. Györfi Sándor ő egy
udvarhelyi cégtől, a ministúdiótól jön.
egy saját termékük, ötletük van, ami ami
Sanyikának a az egyik szívügye, arról
fog szólni, hogy CSS automatizálást
hogyan lehet csinálni, animációkat
és a automatizálást a CSS-ben,
weboldalakra. Ez egy ez is egy technikai
tartalom lesz. Illetve a végén Kis Ruben
fog ő egy független információbiztonsági
szakember, nemrég költözött amúgy haza
Magyarországról. Ő arról fog beszélni,
hogy hogyan lehet webes rendszerekben a
az
adatbiztonsági sérülékenységeket
felfedezni, milyen eszközök vannak rá,
hogyan lehet azt beépíteni a
gyakorlatilag minden webes rendszert
fejlesztő cégnek a a napi rutinjába,
hogy ne csak teszteljük és nézzük, hanem
az a sérülékenységeinket is profiben
tesztrendszerekkel és eszközökkel
viszonylag olcsón tudjuk tesztelni. Jó,
ennyi a páralom szekcióprogram.
És van még egy jokerünk szombatra, akit
nem tudjuk még, hogy hol lesz a
programban, de már megerősítette a
részvételét. Oszkó Péter volt
magyarországi pénzügyminiszter és
jelenleg az O3 Partners az egyik európai
legbefolyásosabb befektetési alapnak az
ügyvezetője is velünk lesz. Még nem
tudjuk pontosan, hogy hogy és miről fog
beszélni, de minden bizonnyal nagyon
érdekes dolgokat fog mondani.
És még
két dolgot szeretnék hozzátenni. Az
egyik az, hogy éptestben épp lélek, nem
csak a a szellemnek kínálunk
programokat, hanem valószínűleg szombat
reggel egy kis terepfutásra is
meginvitáljuk majd a résztvevőket, aki
erre
kíváncsi, illetve Karesnek még annyit
tennék a az előzetes bevezetőjéhez, hogy
még van egy másik rendezvénye is a
klusternek az IT Meetup, ami tipikusan
évente egyszer jelenik meg valahol, és
akkor kicsit kisebb közegben, de a
klustertagok összegyűlnek, és megosztják
egymással a tapasztalataikat, meg
kiértékelik az évet.
No hát szerintem monológnak ennyi elég
volt. Remélem, hogy követő volt.
>> Elképű. Elképesztő. Hát tényleg remélem,
hogy lesz erről egy videófelvétel
mindenről, mert lehetetlen minden részt
venni és
én megdöbbentem most így, hogy láttam,
hogy mennyire izgalmas szakmai programok
lesznek. Személyesen alig várom, hogy
ott tudjak majd lenni. Köszönöm nektek,
hogy itt voltatok és köszönöm, hogy
ezekről a fontos témákról tudtunk
beszélgetni. Akit érdekel a digitális
székelyföld program, az megtalálja a
linket, valamint a a az instrukciókat,
hogy hogyan lehet feliratkozni, hogyan
lehet még jegyet vásárolni. A videó
alatt fogjátok majd a leírásban
meglátni.
És hát igen, köszönöm nektek, hogy itt
voltatok és szép napot nektek. Köszönjük
szépen.
>> Kös szépen.
[Zene]